monsieur le président
la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur les
conclusions du rapport abis la dernière
frontière
à la demande de la mission d'information
exploration protection exploitation des
fonds marins quelle stratégie pour la
France
je vous rappelle que dans ce débat le
gouvernement aura la faculté s'il le
juge nécessaire de prendre la parole
immédiatement après chaque orateur pour
une durée de 2 minutes
l'orateur disposera alors à son tour du
droit de répartie pour une minute
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez donc
si vous le souhaitez répondre après
chaque orateur une fois que celui-ci
aura retrouvé une place dans l'hémicycle
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
de la mission d'information qui a
demandé ce départ monsieur Teva rofritch
rapporteur de la mission d'information
pour 8 minutes
ce rapporteur c'est
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président la
mission d'information chers collègue je
me réjouis que nous puissions débattre
sur les conclusions du rapport que la
mission d'information sur l'exploration
l'exploitation et la protection des
grands fonds marins adopté le 21 juin
dernier le titre que nous avons choisi
pour ce rapport abis la dernière
frontière comporte un point
d'interrogation une interpellation bien
à propos dans son nombreux les défis
pour franchir avec intelligence et
discernement cette barrière de la
connaissance
en effet bien que cela soit
difficilement concevable en 2022 il
ressort de nos travaux qui nous reste
tout ou presque à découvrir des grands
fonds marins ceci s'apparente a bien des
égards à une véritable marine connaîta
et c'est un paradoxe alors que 12 hommes
ont foulé le sol lunaire seul 4 ont
plongé à plus de 10000 mètres de
profondeur
en conséquence nous ne connaîtrions
selon les plus optimistes estimations de
l'Ifremer que 5% de la biodiversité de
l'océan profond et 2% de la bathymétrie
avec une résolution d'un mètre cette
méconnaissance n'est pas propre à la
France qui se situe dans la moyenne des
principales puissances maritimes mais la
France accuse bien quelques retards sur
le plan industriel
en dépit de ses performances reconnues
sur le plan de la recherche et de
l'innovation cette situation résulte à
titre principal des difficultés liées
aux grandes profondeur mais également il
faut le reconnaître des relatifs des
intérêts de longue date de la part des
poids publiques pourtant les enjeux sont
nombreux colossaux même dans un monde
qui va vite et dans la soif de
connaissance et de ressources
alternatives par insatiable au regard
des enjeux de la transition énergétique
souvent comparé un nouvel ruée vers l'or
ou encore à la course aux étoiles
l'accès au grand format que l'on pense
riche en ressources minérale participent
au jeu et en jeu de puissance avec pour
compétiteur la Chine la Russie les
États-Unis la Norvège et de nombreux
autres pays
en parallèle il a aussi été démontré
contrairement à ce que nous pensions
encore récemment que les abysses
abritent une vie abondante disposant de
caractéristiques génétiques
exceptionnelles pour survivre dans ces
milieux hostiles ces écosystèmes doivent
absolument être préservés nous ne sommes
qu'au stade de la description et non de
la compréhension de ces milieux de leurs
interactions de leur fonction sur ce
constat et face à des procédés
industriels d'extraction minière
sous-marine qui n'ont pas atteint leur
maturité la mission d'information
estimait qu'il était prématuré
d'envisager une exploitation
ceci ne doit pas pour autant ne
contraindre à l'immobilisme nous prenons
au contraire un soutien à cru à la
recherche française aux industriels et
aux entreprises au service mobilisés sur
l'exploration je suis en effet persuadé
que la valorisation comme la protection
de ces milieux fragiles passe par une
première étape indispensable de recueil
de connaissances
connaître et comprendre pour protéger et
préserver telles doivent être nous
mettre un mot et je me réjouis monsieur
le ministre de l'appel à projet que le
gouvernement a lancé le 27 septembre
dernier pour 25 millions d'euros dans le
cadre du Plan France 2030 cette première
phase appelle déjà la suivre car les
opportunités développement sont
nombreuses à titre d'exemple il faudrait
3500 ans un robot autonome de type A UV
pour cartographier l'ensemble de la ze
française pourriez-vous monsieur le
ministre nous annoncer la suite du
calendrier pour France 2030
ces enjeux globaux ne doivent pas faire
oublier la dimension locale et
profondément humaine de notre rapport à
la mer qui s'apparente à l'intime dans
certains cultures comme chez nous dans
les outre-mer comme chez moi en
Polynésie française la mère y est
considérée comme le premier garde manger
le trait d'union entre les îles et les
peuples le temple sacré la voix de
l'envol des âmes tout simplement le lieu
où l'on vit en bord de terre ces
dimensions locales est souvent oubliée
comme nous l’ont une animation signalé
les représentants des territoires
ultramarins que nous avons auditionné il
est impératifs d'associer nos
populations nos élus locaux où ce sera
l'échec et le rejet dans nos
collectivités du Pacifique l'impératif
culturel viscérale se joint au respect
des lois organiques et de la
Constitution qui consacre de l'âge
compétence aux collectivités que l'usage
local des noms pays non par défiance à
la nation mais pas fierté de cette
identité particulière en son sein que
l'histoire et la géographie ont fondé
nos territoires d'outre-mer sont bien
aux premières loges de tous ces défis la
DDE française et la deuxième mondiale en
termes de superficie 97% de celle-ci est
ultra marine 4 47% en Polynésie je ne
doute pas monsieur le ministre que vous
trouverez dans ces mots les ressources
pour faire naître la concertation mais
aussi l'esprit d'initiative il y a nuité
chez nous dans ce contexte d'enjeux
multiple nous sommes convaincus que la
France a un rôle essentiel a joué sur
cette immense ze mais également à
l'échelle internationale elle fut l'une
des toutes premières nations à
s'intéresser au grand fonds marins dès
les années 60 elle dispose d'un vivier
scientifique et d'entreprises innovantes
de renommer mondiale la France est un
membre historique actif de la IFM qui
lui octroyait deux contrats
d'exploration dans les eaux
internationales Samarie n'est présente
sur tous les océans la France avec
toutes ses composantes ultramarines et
donc bien incontournable
c'est une chance pour elle autant qu'une
responsabilité que le Président de la
République a fait sienne nous devons
tous ensemble assumer cette
responsabilité devant les nations du
monde en particulier c'est le moins
attentive aux impacts de l'émission de
l'homme dans ces milieux abyssaux hommes
libre toujours tu chériras à la mer nous
disait Baudelaire la France doit porter
au sein de la IFM une position exigeante
quant aux garantie environnementale et
au moyen consacrés à leur respect c'est
les filles sont passionnants et nous
oblige mais ils appellent une fois de
mobilisation de tous les acteurs
concernés en particulier l'État c'est
dans cet esprit de responsabilité que
nous avons formulé 20 recommandations il
faut notamment monsieur le ministre
associé davantage le Parlement clarifier
la gouvernance aujourd'hui peu lisible
et soutenir aussi bien la recherche
française que le tissu industriel par
une commande publique forte et constante
à ce stade nous recommandations ne porte
pas sur l'ouverture de crédit
supplémentaire ni sur les laboration
d'une énième stratégie
mais la confirmation de ce qui a été
conçu et annoncé autour de deux piliers
le pilier civil avec la stratégie
nationale d'exploration d'exploitation
des ressources minérales des grands
fonds marins
issus de travaux collectifs menés par
Jean-Louis levé ce pli était renforcé
par le dixième objectif du plan France
2030 évoqué tantôt le pilier militaire
avec la stratégie de maîtrise des fonds
marins du ministère des armées pour le
premier pilier deux enveloppes
normalement distinctes de 300 millions
d'euros ont été annoncés et validés par
le premier ministre Jean Castex il
ressort néanmoins nos auditions que sa
mise en oeuvre souffrir et d'importage
politique diffus trop faible si tel est
le cas ce serait un échec cuisant pour
notre pays celui de Jules Verne du
Commandant Cousteau mais aussi de
pasteur pourriez-vous nous éclairer
monsieur le ministre sur la politique du
gouvernement faveur de la connaissance
de nos grands fonds marins avec quels
moyens et à quel rythme les deux budget
300 millions en euros sont-ils confirmés
quel regard portez-vous sur les 20
recommandations formulées par notre
mission
regard des tensions géopolitiques en mer
Baltique pouvez-vous aussi nous indiquer
si la France dispose de moyens
suffisants pour assurer la sécurité de
ces infrastructures sous-marines de
communication et d'énergie de nombreuses
questions se posent monsieur le ministre
et ce débat je n'en doute pas permettra
de les éclairer
pour conclure monsieur le ministre chers
collègue je ne pense pas me tromper en
soutenant que nous partageons tous ici
le souhaitent la France confirme son
rang de puissance maritime comme Son
Excellence en matière de recherche et
d'industrie sous-marine nous pouvons
relever tous ensemble ce défi de la
connaissance avec responsabilité
Jules Verne ne s'y est pas trompé en
nous invitant à aimer la mer cette
immense désert où l'homme n'est jamais
seul car il s'en frémirent la vie à ses
côtés nous cédons donc pas l'immobilisme
mais faisons ensemble la démonstration
qu'un modèle vertueux est performant est
possible dans le respect des écosystèmes
et des fonctions vitales de l'océan ce
modèle doit être porté par la France
avec ses outre-mer merci de votre
attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre vous souhaitez
intervenir
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs et
les sénatrices monsieur le Président de
cette mission d'intervention monsieur le
rapporteur je vais te très bref mais je
voulais vraiment prendre ce moment pour
pouvoir faire un tout petit introduction
d'abord pour vous remercier pour la
qualité de ce rapport la qualité de ce
rapport dans un contexte en plus où on
connaît très peu de choses sur cette
matière et donc je crois que vous avez
mené plus d'une soixantaine de 10 ans de
70 pourraient tout à fait précis
peut-être bien 69 vous avez fait un
certain nombre de déplacement dont un en
Norvège et puis on voit que dans ce
rapport il y a la patte de quelqu'un qui
connaît la mère de quelqu'un qui connaît
les enjeux de préservation la
biodiversité marine de quelqu'un qui
connaît là aussi les enjeux de
valorisation de ce patrimoine et
quelqu'un qui au fond mais au cœur de la
priorité de la stratégie pour le
territoire de la polysémie pour tout le
territoire
ultra marin et pour la France la
nécessité bien de faire de la merde des
enjeux maritimes un enjeu à la fois de
lutte contre le changement climatique et
en même temps de souveraineté et donc le
gouvernement et puis tous ceux qui
travaillent sur cette belle politique
ont bien pris connaissance des
recommandations et nous allons avoir
l'occasion à travers les questions des
sénateurs et des sénatrices qui vont ne
qui ne vont pas manquer à d'arriver de
peut-être faire trois points de
clarification le premier c'est qu'il y a
un pilote de l'avion le pilote dans
l'avion c'est le président de la
République puisque c'est une ambition
qui est fortement portée il a eu
l'occasion de le rappeler dans les
différents sommets le sommet des Nations
Unies pour les océans à Lisbonne il a eu
l'occasion de rappeler aussi dans une
belle région que certains nombre de
connaissent ici comme le président et
l'autre président la Bretagne de
rappeler à quel point la connaissance
des fonds marins la connaissance de
l'océan était un enjeu crucial et puis
il y a aussi un pilote de l'avion avec
une instance de décision qui est le
cimer le comité invite thermen
ministériel de la mer où se prennent un
certain nombre de décision ou ses prix
d'ailleurs la décision de faire de
l'exploration des fonds mar une priorité
et puis il y a une deuxième
clarification que vous apportez et je
vous en remercie dans un moment qui
n'était pas simple et vous l'avez fait
je crois quasiment un peu en avance par
rapport à ce que a pu porter le
gouvernement c'est la clarification sur
le fait qu'on devait et que nous
n'allions pas nous engager dans la voie
de l'exploitation et que ce qui nous
guide la stratégie du gouvernement la
stratégie de tous les acteurs c'est
celle d'une meilleure connaissance et
celle de l'exploration c'est celle de la
recherche scientifique et donc nous
allons avancer dans cette voie là en
incluant bien évidemment tous les
territoires j'y reviendrai notamment les
territoires
ultramarins et puis un dernier point de
clarification si je ne peux me permettre
de le faire tout de suite c'est que
l'enveloppe dédiée pour ce magnifique
sujet parce que c'est une aventure
entrepreneuriale sinon bien sûr
nationale c'est aussi une aventure
industrielle puisque notamment sur la
partie militaire on va devoir là aussi
mobiliser un certain nombre de de nos
industriels sur l'U sujet c'est une
enveloppe de 350 millions d'euros en
fait 352 si on compte d'autres
un petit bout de crédit qui sont dans
quelques ministères une enveloppe qui
est forte c'est un signal politique
envoyé pour faire de l'exploration des
fonds marins un sujet prioritaire donc
je vous remercie encore à vous aussi
d'être présent ce soir pour discuter de
ce magnifique sujet parce que c'est un
sujet qui a très à la question on a
souveraineté durant l'urgence écologique
et d'accapacité au fond aussi à répondre
aux grands enjeux pour notre concitoyens
et pour les générations qui vont arriver
merci merci monsieur le ministre je vous
ai permis de développer complètement
même si vous dépassiez un petit peu et
pour la suite on s'est resté dans le
dans le temps
monsieur Gérard Laennec pour le groupe
CRCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
monsieur le président de la Mission
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues comme mes collègues j'ai
participé donc avec beaucoup d'intérêt à
cette mission d'information sur les
fonds marins
j'ai lu attentivement le rapport et je
dois dire que je partage l'essentiel des
conclusions qui en découlent en effet si
l'Amazonie le poumon vert de notre
planète il sollicitent à ce type de
l'attention du monde au moindre des
parts de feu nos
océans sont sûrement le poumon bleu
indispensable à notre avenir
le rôle des océans dans la régulation du
réchauffement climatique est indéniable
et les abysses en sont peut-être la
réserve naturellement préservée
au même titre que nous nous souchions de
l'état de nos forêts de nos sols la fin
de garantir la qualité la qualité de
notre ère la bonne santé de nous océans
doit donc aussi demeurer une de nos
préoccupations majeures dans l'intérêt
de notre planète et des générations
futures
la France a le deuxième espace maritime
au monde et a donc une responsabilité
particulière de ce point de vue là
ne nous comparons pas à ceux qui
sauteraient les étapes passez-moi
l'expression
en sautant des étapes en confondant
vitesse et précipitations et en espérant
trouver ici
j'allais dire une nouvelle manne une
nouvelle manne énergétique
une nouvelle manne peut-être économique
peut-être une nouvelle manne financière
on sait que l'enjeu est trop important
pour jouer à ce jeu là
alors que le Président de la République
souhaitait le site en octobre 2021 le
départ du nerf de cette dernière
frontière que représente les profondeurs
maritimes à l'issue de ses missions
d'information
nous appelons en vérité à de la prudence
et qu'il nous soit permis qu'il me soit
permis ici de souligner que les
infléchissements intervenus depuis sa
déclarations sont de nature à me
permettre d'affirmer ici que monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez vraisemblablement
d'ores et déjà peut-être été entendu
pour autant
la fascination
que constitue ces fonds marins puisqu'on
ne les connaît pas
n'empêche pas l'action
et notre méconnaissance des fonds marins
nous éclaire au moins sur la nécessité
de mieux connaître je ne citerai pas ici
Paul Valéry et son regard sur le monde
actuel mais il disait déjà en son temps
que l'avenir serait cognitif et qu'il y
avait besoin de connaître et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le rapporteur 4
personnes seulement ont observé les
fonds marins au-delà de 10000 mètres de
profondeur c'est donc trois fois moins
que les personnes ayant foulé la surface
de la Lune
donc la recherche de la meilleure
connaissance des abysses et donc une
impérieuse nécessité et pour cela il
faudra des moyens techniques mais aussi
des moyens humains
les organismes existent nous les avons
d'ailleurs rencontrés vous les avez
rencontrés aussi je pense à livreur que
je salue au passage à l'Institut
français de la recherche d'un
exploitation de la mer au chaume que
nous avons rencontré aussi et qui sont
déjà d'ailleurs qui ont déjà quelques
notoriété au-delà de nos frontières
et il sera aussi important d'associer
pleinement et je dirais même de confier
sûrement le pilotage du suivi de ce
sujet
allez disons-le à nos collègues
d'outre-mer
je pense que la mission telle qu'elle a
été accomplie constitue par elle-même
une invitation en tout cas permettez-moi
de dire ici qu'il s'agit d'un souhait
librement donc exprimé alors en tant que
Breton
et peut-être avec d'autres protons qui
nous regardent ce soir
j'en suis même convaincu
et depuis les côtes d'Armor auxquelles
je tiens tant monsieur le monsieur le
ministre
je serai également ravi de participer de
lire les résultats à venir de ces études
parce qu'il faut continuer à étudier
elles seront indispensables car je le
redis et j'en termine s'il est vrai que
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme
science sans connaissance n'est que
démagogie alors
à bon entendeur et merci de votre
attention
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup et merci à vous chers
collègues d'abord je partage votre amour
des Côtes-d'Armor je partage aussi votre
amour des citations simplement vous dire
que bien évidemment nous partageons et
le gouvernement le président de la
République a eu l'occasion de le
rappeler notamment à Lisbonne sortait
ensuite redis je le redis ici de devant
vous sur la distinction et le fait que
nous souhaitons être dans l'exploration
et non pas dans l'exploitation donc je
partage votre prudence je partage aussi
votre exigence vous l'avez dit j'allais
dire en creux non vous l'avez dit de
manière très claire sur la nécessité
d'impliquer nos collègues d'outre-mer
nous le ferons dans le cadre notamment
du CNML le Conseil national de la mer et
du littoral parce qu'on va devoir
déployer d'ici un an la stratégie
nationale de la mer électorale qui
inclut une partie grand fond et donc
nous le rosons l'occasion de revenir
vers vous avec un certain nombre de
propositions d'échéance de manière de
vous impliquer et donc je crois que le
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure il doit
être au niveau politique le président de
la République la première ministre et
puis ici votre serviteur au secrétariat
data de la mer mais il doit se faire
avec une exigence d'impliquer de
co-construire cette stratégie parce que
vous êtes à la fois les premiers acteurs
et puis ceux qui aussi vivent de plein
fouet la question du changement
climatique partout sur les territoires
et puis nous partageons l'exigence que
vous avez évoqué de partager la
connaissance c'est le dernier point que
l'on a évoqué lors du comité de pilotage
France 2030 et on a demandé et on va
financer des actions de partage de la
connaissance de vulgarisation de
communication de ce que nous faisons
parce que je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'aussi on peut susciter des vocations
et renforcer la sociabilisation de nos
concitoyens et de tout le monde à la
protection des océans et de la
biodiversité marine merci monsieur le
ministre vous souhaitez répliquer chers
collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
Folliot pour le groupe innocentriste
pour 4 minutes
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je voudrais saluer le
président de notre commission Michel
canevé le rapporteur tevarovs Autriche
pour la qualité du travail qu'ils ont su
mené et tout ce qu'ils ont su impulser
dans le cadre donc de cette mission
si plusieurs milliers d'êtres humains
ont franchi l'Everest le point culminant
de notre planète
si plusieurs centaines de personnes plus
de 300 personnes sont allées dans
l'espace si
12 personnes 12 êtres humains ont marché
sur la Lune
seule une poignée sont allés au plus
profond de la terre donc sous la mer à
dans les abysses et ceci montre
finalement tout l'enjeu et toute
l'importance de la marée incognita
puisque si nous connaissons relativement
bien la partie la plus superficielle de
nos océans le reste est inconnu que ça
soit la masse d'eau sachant que la
profondeur moyenne est
supérieur à 3800 mètres donc au niveau
de nos océans et si nous connaissons
cette partie supérieure de la masse
d'eau nous ne connaissons pas l'autre
partie celle qui est la plus profonde
ensuite nous avons un autre enjeu et un
autre élément important c'est celui
effectivement par rapport au fond marin
à proprement parler au-delà de la masse
d'eau et dans ce cadre je crois qu'il
est il est important de garder le
paramètre de sagesse qui a été celui que
vous nous proposez et que nous vous
proposons monsieur le ministre dans le
cadre de ce rapport celui de la prudence
mais prudence ne veut pas dire naïveté
parce que
en droit il y a ce qui est reste nul
lisse et reste communiste c'est-à-dire
les biens qui sont communs à l'humanité
et les biens qui sont à personne et que
dans la peluche chacun peut s'approprier
il y a une logique qui a été une logique
finalement d'appropriation de ces fonds
marins au travers du problème de la
problématique et des enjeux d'extra
plats pour lequel je veux dire notre
pays a participé c'est engagé et ce sont
près de d'un million de kilomètres
carrés supplémentaires que nous avons
obtenu en termes de capacité de pouvoir
maîtriser les ressources et les
possibilités sur sur ces fonds c'est un
point et un élément qui est un élément
important mais pour autant nous devons
avoir conscience que les fonds marins
aussi quand même une réalité économique
aujourd'hui 30% du gaz et du Pétrole
exploitée dans le monde les offshore
donc vient de sous la mer je vais pas
revenir sur les enjeux relatifs au
gazoduc on en a beaucoup entendu parler
ces derniers jours ainsi que par rapport
au câble sous-marin avec tous les enjeux
qui peut y avoir en terme de sécurité et
par rapport à tout cela moi je voudrais
moins de terminer mon propos monsieur le
ministre attiré votre attention sur un
point un élément c'est celui de l'avenir
du Nautile il a été décidé trop
hâtivement à mon goût de d'arrêter
l'exploitation du Nautile à partir de
2028 pour moi c'est une erreur plus
qu'une erreur c'est une faute pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
ce que peut faire un sous-marin des
drones ne le feront pas de la même façon
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que après un recarénage en
2028 le Nautil pourra fonctionner encore
une bonne dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années et le dernier point je conclus
par là Monsieur monsieur le Président
c'est que la France fait partie des cinq
nations qui ont cette capacité à pouvoir
aller à -6000 mètres de profondeur avec
des bâtiments habités et le fait de
sortir de ce club fermé
et et non seulement un problème par
rapport à la recherche scientifique mais
aussi et surtout monsieur le Président
je conclus c'est une simple perspective
d'économie d'un million d'euros qui
serait assez catastrophique par rapport
aux enjeux qui sont prégnants en la
matière je vous remercie
merci chers collègues j'étais très
tolérant et donc il n'y aura pas de
réplique pour Monsieur folio mais pour
le ministre il peut y en avoir une
allez-y monsieur le ministre ne
confondez pas monsieur follus et moi
même si on se connaît sur d'autres bancs
merci beaucoup monsieur faut lui
monsieur le sénateur et je sais toutes
vos applications sur ce sujet peut-être
pour vous rassurer on est dans la
prudence ce soir et donc vous rassurer
pour vous dire qu'il n'y a pas de
naïveté de la part de la France il n'y a
pas de naïveté de la part du
gouvernement on a bien conscience que
les fonds marins les grands fonds marins
sont aussi un enjeu stratégique et c'est
pour ça que à côté de cette stratégies
de recherche de la connaissance de
recherche marine nous avons déployé nous
développons avec le ministère des armées
une stratégie de maîtrise des fonds
marins pour être en capacité notamment
sur les câbles sous-marins sur la
surveillance de notre espace maritime et
le rapporteur connaît bien à la fois ces
enjeux là il a nécessité d'accélérer
d'amplifier sur
les moyens notamment dans la cas de la
loi de programmation militaire notre
capacité en mer sous la mer aussi à
déployer de l'innovation à déployer des
moyens de surveillance et puis pour vous
répondre très concrètement sur le
Nautile c'est une des possibilités qui
sera donnée dans le cadre des
financements France 2030 et donc je
prends l'engagement ici devant vous de
regarder ça de manière très précise pour
voir s'il est possible s'il est
souhaitable et si nous allons nous
engager dans la voie de poursuivre et
bien le financement de
cet instrument comme vous l'avez très
bien dit qui est stratégique et puis je
terminerai peut-être pour répondre non
pas qu'on en revient toujours à la
Bretagne mais c'était le même sujet que
que vous pourrez répondre
à notre sénateur des Côtes d'Armor pour
lui dire que il peut avoir accès aux
résultats de la campagne de cet été
c'est disponible sur Internet et c'est
le blog de la mission hermond Dieu
Hermann 2 pardon vous n'êtes pas Dieu
Hermon 2 et donc vous pouvez avoir accès
à toutes les informations c'est aussi un
des éléments de partage de la
connaissance et de la science merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre allez je
redonne 30 secondes s'il le veut a fait
les folio
juste monsieur le ministre par rapport
aux Antilles je rappelle c'est un
million d'euros mais simplement il y a
une nécessité de prendre plusieurs
années pour former les opérateurs du
sous-marin et que si on ne prend pas
rapidement la décision de le poursuivre
et donc il n'y aura pas cette capacité à
pouvoir former c'est à dire qu'à un
moment donné on va se retrouver avec un
sous-marin sans les opérateurs et je
crois que c'est un enjeu important et je
terminerai par le fait que si on veut
donner cette dimension de rêve pour nos
enfants il faut aussi que celui-ci
puisse être incarné et et donc les
opérateurs d'une ont-ils font partie
aussi de ce rêve merci cher collègue la
parole à Monsieur Stéphane Artano pour
le groupe RDSE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ce président de la Maison
d'information monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues lors de son discours sur
le plan de relance France 2030 le
président de la République déclarait que
les fonds marins je le cite sont d'un
levier extraordinaire pour la
compréhension du vivant il ne faut pas
laisser dans l'inconnu une partie du
globe si plus de 61% de la surface de la
terre est couverte par des océans les
grands fonds marins restent très peu
connus selon les scientifiques 95%. des
océans profonds on reste encore
inexplorés je rappellerai trois chiffres
à dessin pour se rendre compte de
l'ampleur de cette méconnaissance il est
actuellement recensé environ 250 000
espèces vivantes sous-marine mais selon
Jean-Marc Daniel directeur de
département chargé de l'exploration des
grands fonds marins et frères on
pourrait découvrir vraisemblablement
entre 1 million et 10 millions de
nouvelles espèces
au-delà de la découverte de nouvelles
espèces les fonds marins recèlent de
nombreuses ressources minières très
convoitées
manganèse ou le nickel ces métaux entre
notamment dans la composition faut-il le
rappeler débattre électriques et les
monts incontournables pour l'avenir de
la décarbonation de la production
d'énergie et sans stockage il est vrai
qu'à l'heure où l'exploration des grands
fonds marins s'accélèrent dans le monde
la France a des pays pionniers ça a été
rappelé de l'exploration des océans doit
aussi renforcer ces efforts pour rester
dans la course et maîtriser sa
souveraineté dans son espace maritime
deuxième plus vaste domaine maritime au
monde après les États-Unis et ce grâce à
nos outre-mer notre pays a souvent été
présenté comme un défenseur du monde
marin
or dans un contexte où toutes les
puissances maritimes renforcent leur
développement technologique et leur
programme d'exploration dans les eaux
sous leur juridiction comme dans les ont
internationales d'ailleurs la
problématique de l'exploitation des
grands fonds marins refait surface il
faut noter que l'exploitation minière en
haute mer constitue pour deux nombreuses
entreprises privées une opportunité de
développement en particulier dans le
secteur industriel comme la production
d'engins sous-marins d'avenir cependant
cette exploitation inquiète de nombreux
scientifiques et ONG car elle implique
évidemment des dégradations
irréversibles de notre écosystème et de
la biodiversité avec notamment un effet
immédiat sur la chaîne alimentaire
océanique
ces craintes sont plus que légitimes et
on ne peut les écarter d'un revers de la
main c'est pourquoi je les rejoins quand
à leur revendication de renforcer avant
tout notre connaissance des profondeurs
il s'agit d'un préalable indispensable à
l'élaboration d'un cadre juridique
d'exploitation minière le plus
respectueux de l'environnement possible
ces raisons d'ailleurs justifié le
moratoire qui a été adopté seul le
ministre je m'interroge naturellement
sur la position du gouvernement sujet
vous avez commencé à déflorer le sujet
tout à l'heure en introduction des
cahiers la politique que vous souhaitez
mettre en œuvre pour l'exploration et
l'exploitation des fonds marins
comprendrez que nous soyons un peu
perdus parfois entre la déclaration en
juillet dernier du président de la
République lors de la conférence les
Nations unies dans laquelle il appelle à
l'élaboration d'un cadre légal pour
mettre un coup d'arrêt à l'exploitation
minière des fonds haute mer et ses
déclarations précédentes soutenant la
quête d'une extraction minière en eau
profonde
la publication des excellents travaux de
la mission d'information sur
l'exploration et la protection des fonds
marins dont nous débattons aujourd'hui
sont évidemment à pic
ainsi je souscris à la recommandation de
nos collègues visant à temporiser sur
une prospection et une exploitation
prématurée des ressources minières dans
l'attente d'accueillir une connaissance
scientifique suffisante sur la question
néanmoins comme cela a été souligné par
le rapport et rappeler tout à l'heure
par un orateur cette prudence ne doit
pas être synonyme d'immobilisme et nous
extraire de la compétition mondiale à ce
titre l'État doit s'impliquer pleinement
dans la structuration d'une base
industrielle et technologique souveraine
et compétitive au niveau international
ça a été rappelé notamment par notre
rapporteur car nous devons garder à
l'esprit que d'autres puissances
mondiales comme les États-Unis ou la
Chine sont moins timorés en la matière
dans tous les cas le pilotage de la
politique a mené sur les abysses au
regard du caractère transversal des
enjeux mérite de gagner en visibilité on
ne peut donc que soutenir la création
d'un ministère de la mer de plein
exercice compétents pour établir une
stratégie maritime centralisée pour des
fonds marins comme la propose la mission
d'information
enfin en tant qu'élu ultramarin
j'insiste sur cette recommandation ainsi
que sur celle de renforcer en
particulier les moyens humains et
financiers d'Ifremer notamment quel que
soit la position du gouvernement cette
politique doit absolument associer le
Parlement et les outre-mer ou différents
stades d'élaboration de pilotage et de
suivi et vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
ministre on est fait la question des
grands fonds marins ne doit pas être
uniquement abordé sous le prisme des
avis des instancesétatiques et des
experts l'opposition ferme des habitants
de Wallis-et-Futuna en 2017 et 2012 doit
nous servir de leçon cette décision doit
être prise de manière transparente et
démocratique car elle concerne
directement l'ensemble des personnes qui
résident dans des régions où les modes
de vie économie la culture sont
influencés par l'environnement maritime
dès lors nous devons établir tous
ensemble une stratégie maritime
respectueuse de la biodiversité et des
écosystèmes sur quoi elle pourrait
susciter la méfiance des territoires et
engendrer ainsi des blocages j'espère
monsieur le ministre que vos éclairages
apporteront plus de visibilité je vous
remercie merci chers collègues monsieur
le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
pour répondre d'abord à votre question
qui n'est pas la première mais qui était
celle qui au fond qui était centrale
puisque elle va le guider à la fois les
financements la stratégie et puis le
travail qu'on aura amené ensemble la
première c'est de vous rappeler en effet
la déclaration du Président de la
République qui a indiqué à Lisbonne qui
fallait créer le cadre juridique pour
stopper les activités manières en haute
mer et ne pas autoriser des activités de
nouvelles qui mettraient en danger les
écosystèmes comme nous l'avons fait en
France pour les aidants
ceci signifie très clairement que depuis
la déclaration du Président de la
République à Lisbonne la France s'engage
dans sa stratégie dans ses
investissements sur uniquement l'enjeu
de l'exploration et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qu'il y a guidé tous les financements
les 350 millions qui vont devoir être
déployés mais que dans le même temps et
c'est tout au fond la bataille que l'on
doit mener aussi à l'international que
ce soit dans le cadre du traité bbnj en
bon grand breton Bayonne national
juridiction c'est la protection de la
haute mer parce que même si la France ne
s'engage pas dans cette voie là on a
conscience parce qu'on n'est pas naïf
que d'autres peuvent le faire et que
donc il nous faut comme dans tous les
sujets comme en tout temps arriver à
convaincre nos autres partenaires ou les
autres pays de s'engager dans cette voie
là et donc il faut arriver à codifier
les choses qui ne veut pas dire que nous
nous le faisons et c'est pas ce que nous
souhaitons faire c'est à dire pour ça
que l'on a fait sur les autres carbure
sur la montagne d'or dans d'autres
endroits on a été je crois en avance et
donc ce que nous disons très clairement
c'est qu'il faut que la France soit
impliquée aussi dans les instances
internationales pour convaincre pour
convaincre que pour protéger notre
biodiversité pour protéger nos essais il
nous faut avoir ce cadre strict qui
permettent au fond et bien de ne pas
endommager les océans et la biodiversité
marine
merci Monsieur le Ministre une réplique
non pas de réplique donc la parole est à
madame Micheline Jacques pour le groupe
les républicains pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cher collègue on ne peut
naturellement aborder un sujet maritime
sans parler des Outre-mer puisque c'est
au tour de la France ultramarine que se
situe 97% de sa zone économique
exclusive équivalent à 17 fois sa
surface terrestre comme de nombreux
collègues n'ont pas manqué de le
rappeler notre pays est donc bien un
pays maritime à la lumière de ces
chiffres en peine donc à croire que la
stratégie maritime française ne soit pas
davantage affirmé le rapport de nos
collègues Michel canvett était Varo
frites d'une grande richesse est un
mensonce un plaidoyer particulièrement
nourri en faveur d'une politique
maritime ambitieuse qui doit aller
au-delà des eaux sur jassantes pour
partir à la conquête des profondeurs
marines avec ce débat et celui qui se
tiendra demain sur la stratégie maritime
à la demande de la délégation aux
outre-mer
ne peut que se réjouir de la séquence
maritime qui s'ouvre preuve s'il en
fallait de la vigilance particulière du
Sénat sur ces questions la mission de
formation formule ainsi de nombreuses
préconisations en vue de dessiner
l'architecture du pilotage de la
stratégie d'exploration des grands fonds
marins elle ne peut en effet se
concevoir sans identifier les acteurs
qui l'incarneront et la déploie à cet
égard il va sans dire que j'approuve la
nomination de membres au sein du
gouvernement en charge de la mer mais
l'exhortation à une politique ambitieuse
est aussi le signe que la volonté
politique de l'État dans sa continuité
d'ailleurs n'est pas à la mesure du
potentiel que recèle la mère française
c'est pourquoi je pense que ce n'est pas
tant le rang protocolaire du ministre
qui compte que la volonté au sommet de
l'État au sein du gouvernement tout
entier le Parlement devra en outre être
pleinement associé en vue de la
sécurisation juridique des grands fonds
marins que le vide juridique les entoure
fragilisent dans le Code Minier
l'imprécision compte à leur exploitation
fait encourir un risque et il s'agit de
sécuriser ce patrimoine pour ne pas
laisser se développer des initiatives
d'autres pays qui pourraient se faire
d'ailleurs au détriment des Outre-mer
légiférer c'est protéger le patrimoine
marin son intégrité et par ton autre
souveraineté la mer étant une partie de
notre territoire par ailleurs au moment
où la délégation aux outre-mer rouvre
ses travaux sur la différenciation
territoriale je suis sensible à la place
que la mission accorde aux collectivités
d'outre-mer dans la coordination de la
stratégie pour les fonds marins
si elle juge leur exploitation
prématurée à ce stade de leur
connaissance elle invite à se placer
dans une logique d'anticipation la
recherche et l'exploration ouvre là
aussi des perspectives économiques et
scientifiques qui devrait placer les
territoires ultramarins au cœur de la
politique des grands fonds marins c'est
depuis la terre que l'on conquiert la
mer et de ce point de vue les outre-mer
constituent des bases avancées
géostratégiques mais des bazarières
notamment pour la recherche scientifique
pour autant les représentants les
collectivités ultramarines auditionnées
en unanimement déplorer l'absence
d'informations et d'associations à
l'élaboration de la stratégie 2021 elle
constitue pourtant un enjeu économique
social éducatif d'intégration régionale
qui mérite d'être pensée avec les
outre-mer et pas seulement pour eux
enfin qu'ils sont par pleinement de ce
défi
une vision maritime ambitieuse c'est
aussi la possibilité pour les
territoires ultramarins de renforcer
leur compétences locales tournez leur
jeunesse vers de nouveaux métiers la
cartographie est bathymétrie doit offrir
une connaissance précise des grands
fonds et partager avec les collectivités
en outre l'approche globale des travaux
de nos collègues tient compte de la
place des populations de leur nécessaire
adhésion et l'indispensable respect de
leur représentation pour assurer le
succès d'une stratégie plus généralement
les profondeurs marines de nos zones
économiques exclusives sont dotées d'une
richesse minérale exceptionnelle que ce
soit en lait minéralisations
hydrothermales les encrûtements
cobaltifaires ou la présence de nodules
des scientifiques relèvent pas moins de
27 méthodes différents un déplacement à
Brest avec la mission était l'occasion
de découvrir le travail remarquable de
l'ifère dont le rôle central aux côtés
des autres instituts le BRGM le CNRS et
le pour citer les principaux méritent
d'être souligné il valent à notre pays
de figurer dans le top 10 des grands
pays océaniques oui la recherche doit
être soutenue elle est la clé de la
maîtrise des profondeurs et malgré la
période troublée qui impose des
arbitrages la recherche stratégique ne
devrait pas faire l'objet de compromis
nous devons également placer l'industrie
au cœur de l'ambition pour les grands
fonds marins dans cette politique les
outre-mer devront trouver une place de
premier plan et bénéficier des fruits du
développement des activités autour des
profondeurs maritimes qui les entourent
j'en terminerai par un mot sur la
coopération en matière maritime elle est
incontournable et se situe au niveau
international et pour une bonne
intégration des Outre-mer également
régionales je vous remercie merci chers
collègues
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup madame la sénatrice et
merci de votre implication aussi sur ce
sujet comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
rappeler bien évidemment à la fois dans
la lecture et puis la mise en œuvre des
recommandations de ce rapport nous avons
une attention toute particulière pour
les territoires ultramants pour être
très concret à quel niveau les
territoires
ultramarins les collectivités
d'outre-mer vont être impliquées d'abord
parce que cette politique maritime cette
stratégie maritime qui intègre la
stratégie des grands fonds et porter au
plus haut niveau de l'État avec le cimer
ce comité intermédiaire il y aura bien
évidemment le ministre des outre-mer et
bien évidemment toutes les collectifs
visités qui travaillent ensuite dans la
déclinaison il y aura le comité le
pardon le Conseil national de la mère et
du littoral qui inclut dedans des élus
d'outre-mer des personnes qui
représentent ces magnifiques territoire
et puis ce que je vous propose parce
qu'on a besoin aussi d'avoir parfois un
peu plus de temps d'avoir des cadres
informels il y avait un groupe de
concertation qui existait qui est piloté
par le Secrétariat général à la mer et
qui le fond coordonne administrativement
tout ça et donc nous allons intégrer
tous les élus des Outre-mer qui le
souhaitent pour travailler avec les ONG
les scientifiques pour et bien faire
entendre la voix des outre-mer et tout
ça servira à nourrir la stratégie
nationale mère et littorale qui sera
déployé en 203 et puis nous allons aussi
développer cette planification
stratégique des grands fonds marins et
donc ça veut dire planification
stratégique se mettent en lien aussi
avec les stratégies des territoires
parce qu'on sait bien que et bien les
élections sont pas toujours au même
moment et donc il y a des stratégies qui
sont faites par un territoire et puis la
stratégie nationale et puis la stratégie
ministérielle et donc cette
planification stratégique du territoire
français de la zone maritime française
elle se fera avec cette volonté de
porter d'ici 2023 une véritable
planification stratégique des grands
fonds marins qui se fera territoire par
territoire avec bien évidemment cette
ambition nationale cette impression pour
notre nation
merci Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues pas de réplique
pas de réplique la parole est à Monsieur
Joël guerriot pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues les Français aiment la mer
mais ils la connaissent mal disait
Jacques Chirac la surface maritime de la
France est en effet ça vient d'être
appelé 17 fois supérieur à sa surface
terrestre c'est-à-dire à quel point il
est difficile d'appréhender la présence
française sur tous les océans ces vastes
espaces contiennent un grand potentiel
de ressources maritimes parmi celles-ci
se trouve les ressources de nos fonds
marins et nous ne connaissons que très
peu ses fonds tout le monde l'a rappelé
il est en effet relativement difficile
et coûteux bien sûr d'explorer les
abysses surtout lorsque les profondeurs
se comptent en milieu de mètres de
précieuses ressources minières sont
néanmoins susceptibles de s'y trouver
nous ne sommes pas les seuls nous
intéresser à ces ressources en Europe
l'Allemagne et la Norvège sont en train
de creuser les cas elle reste bien sûr
encore très loin derrière les deux
superpuissances que sont les États-Unis
et la Chine
certains pays s'intéressent de près à
nos territoires notamment dans le
Pacifique pour les ressources qu'il
pourrait contenir mais aussi car nos
fonds contiennent des infrastructures
stratégiques câbles de communication
mais aussi packline de récent sabotage
souligne leur caractère stratégiques
ainsi que la volonté de certains acteurs
de les instrumentaliser l'une de nos
premières priorités doit être donc
l'exploration dresser l'état des lieux
de nos fonds marins est indispensable
pour préserver efficacement notre
biodiversité cela les tout autant pour
déterminer l'existence de ressources
minières il nous semble à cet égard que
la France doit investir suffisamment
dans la technologie pour mieux contrôler
ces espaces maritimes les drôles sont
une technologie particulièrement utile à
l'exploration sous-marine il est
essentiel que nous puissions la
maîtriser les recommandations du rapport
d'information traduisent la nécessité
d'investir ce sujet notre groupe est
bien sûr favorable renforcement du rôle
du Parlement dans le développement de
ces projets il est nécessaire de
parvenir à des solutions équilibrées
pour permettre à la France d'avancer
nous sommes également très favorables au
retour d'un ministère de la mer adopter
un exercice cela contribuerait à
redonner toute sa place à cette
dimension majeure l'histoire démontre
amplement que la maîtrise des mers est
une nappe est un importante facteur de
puissance et puis petit paragraphe sur
la Bretagne
monsieur le Président mon cher Michel
canvett le mercredi 24 octobre 2019
reste gravé dans ma mémoire avec
amertume le débattu de la Loi relative
la délimitation des régions nous
défendions ensemble une Bretagne à cinq
départements nous voulions créer un pôle
mondial de compétitivité mère conciliant
tous les domaines de l'innovation de la
recherche jusqu'à la construction navale
et coniquement la Bretagne à cinq
départements c'était la constitution
d'une vraie région maritime avec en
façade deux grands ports Brest et Nantes
Saint-Nazaire labra la Bretagne berceau
naturel des activités en lien avec la
mer est une porte naturelle pour
conduire une grande politique maritime
utile à l'ensemble de la France alors où
l'essentiel du trafic mondial des
marchandises s'effectue par voie
maritime nous n'avons pas été entendus
et aujourd'hui nous constatons une perte
de compétitivité des ports français avec
des besoins d'investissement important
j'ai bien entendu monsieur le ministre
qu'il y aurait une coordination
nationale il y aura un peu moins de
régions et plus marqué sur le maritime
ça serait plus simple il n'est pas
réaliste de croire qu'avec des moyens
limités la France serait en mesure de
rivaliser avec des capacités américaines
ou chinoises il reste bien entendu
indispensable que notre pays soit en
mesure de garantir sa souveraineté sur
l'ensemble de ces espaces pour être
crédible tout en tenant compte de nos
capacités la France peut compter sur la
conclusion de partenariat avec des
puissances qui partagent ces intérêts en
juin dernier monsieur le ministre le
ministre des de nos armées de la défense
a signé un accord de soutien logistique
avec Singapour nous nous en réjouissons
puisqu'il bénéficiera aux armées de nos
deux pays et nous ne disposons pas de
moyens militaires qui nous permettent de
contrôler intégralement les vastes
étendues de ce qu'ils sont sous notre
juridiction à l'inverse Singapour
détient d'abord en moyenne mais n'a pas
l'espace suffisant pour les déployer
cela pourrait servir de base à d'autres
que partenariats globaux qui permettrait
donc de protéger notre patrimoine marin
j'espère que la construction d'un
nouveau porte-avions il y a parfois
quelques bruits sur la question se fera
bien comme prévu en renforçant nos
coopérations et alliances face à des
super puissances qui ne cesse d'envahir
les espaces marins
nos partenaires européens disposent en
efforts de capacité significatives la
Suède actuellement construit la coque
d'une frégate de 7000 tonnes frégate de
7000 tonnes c'est ce que c'est plus que
n'importe quel autre frégate que nous
ayons en France et nombre de systèmes
sur cette frégate qui ont été embarqué
son français
les fonds marins seront l'un des
prochains enjeux de rivalité entre les
États il faudra bien sûr
être en capacité de défendre nos
intérêts il s'est constituent ces fonds
marins d'importance de développement
économique c'est un rendez-vous qu'il ne
faut pas manquer et comme je vois que le
président regarde mes notes c'est le top
c'est bien terminé monsieur le Président
rassurez-vous j'ai tenu les horaires
merci cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
il va retourner il va retourner à sa
place
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur d'abord vous avez cité
quelqu'un je cité aussi un grand breton
qui disait sur notre nécessité aussi de
renforcer la connaissance de nos
concitoyens à la mer Eric Tabarly qui
disait la mère c'est ce qu'on les
Français dans le dos quand ils sont à la
plage et donc je crois que depuis on a
fait beaucoup de progrès et on essaye de
le faire ici en tout cas ce ministère
mais il y a un enjeu là aussi partout
sur les territoires de sensibilisation
et de plus grandes connaissances d'abord
peut-être je vais essayer de je sais pas
vous convaincre mais en tout cas vous
essuyez à quel point le fait d'avoir un
secrétaire d'État placé auprès de la
première ministre permet justement de
répondre à tous les enjeux que vous avez
évoqués puisque étant rattaché à la
première ministre nous avons j'ai la
légitimité d'agir en interministérialité
et on voit bien que les enjeux maritimes
les enjeux de la mer c'est à la fois le
littoral donc la terre c'est à la fois
les fonds marins à la fois la haute mer
c'est c'est l'écologie c'est le défense
c'est le militaire c'est l'aménagement
du territoire et donc je le vois tous
les jours avec beaucoup de force à quel
point ça m'évite beaucoup de réunions
interministérielles ça permet d'avancer
beaucoup plus rapidement et puis ça me
permet de mobiliser tous les services de
l'État pour atteindre cet objectif et
bien de faire de la merde de faire de
l'océan un objectif prioritaire et donc
avec notamment le secrétaire général à
la mer et puis surtout la Direction
Générale des Affaires maritimes de la
pêche et de l'aquaculture c'est plus de
300 agents c'est six mois que cette
direction existe ça nous permet de
déployer cette fonction intermittelle de
le faire du mieux que nous pouvons mais
je crois avec beaucoup plus d'efficacité
de cohérence et de convergence et donc
sans l'enjeu notamment de la maîtrise de
des fonds marins au fond reconnaître que
la mer est un enjeu de compétition
stratégique et bien j'arrive à le faire
nous arrivons à le faire de manière
beaucoup plus efficace parce que
justement nous sommes rattachés à la
première ministre et donc nous pouvons
déployer avec le ministère de la défense
avec le soustrattariat général de la
Défense nationale une stratégie con
coordonnées cohérente sur l'exploration
la connaissance et en même temps cet
enjeu de sécurité de surveillance et de
contrôle de nos espaces maritimités donc
vous le voyez je sais pas si je vous ai
convaincu mais je vous ai démontré à
quel point c'était intéressant et
important d'avoir ce rôle
interministériel pour les enjeux
maritimes merci Monsieur le Ministre pas
de réplique la parole est à Monsieur
Jacques ferrique pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour 5
minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
mission de rapporteur chers collègues je
vais commencer par une citation dont je
crois que nous allons finir par la
connaître par coeur vu que ce dossier du
troisième à l'affaire mais je pense
qu'elle le mérite ouvrons les guillemets
nous devons élaborer un cadre légal pour
mettre un coup d'arrêt à l'exploitation
minière des fonds en haute mer et ne pas
autoriser de nouvelles activités qui
mettraient en danger les écosystèmes ce
sont donc les termes exacts par lesquels
le président de la République le pilote
de l'avion a défini la ligne française à
Lisbonne en juin cette clarté il faut le
dire à trancher avec la confusion les
ambiguïtés qui jusqu'ici caractérisaient
la politique française à l'égard des
ressources minérales des fonds marins
c'était ce défaut de lisibilité dont le
rapport de notre mission d'information
adresser le juste constat notre mission
a pointé d'ailleurs je cite un
éclatement de la gouvernance entre
divers ministères dont aucun ne paraît
jouer de véritable rôle fédérateur la
stratégie française se brouillait dans
trois démarches différentes celle du
rapport levé qui vient de revoir la
stratégie de 2015 sur l'exploration et
l'exploitation minière qui fut notre
rapport de mission l'indique un échec la
stratégie militaire qui travaille à
maîtriser tout ce qui se joue de
sensible dans les profondeurs enfin on
le sait la stratégie financière France
2030 qui affecte 310 millions d'euros
spatial et à la mer les déclarations
présidentielles lors de l'annonce de
cette stratégie France 2030 avait des
accents très très enthousiastes pour
l'Eldorado recevant je cite 84% des
réserves de nos minerais on comprend
donc que la déclaration de Lisbonne
celle que citais en ouverture se
positionnant contre l'exploitation
minière des océans et en faveur d'un
cadre légal international contraignant
et surpris ce qui avait jusqu'ici cru
comprendre que l'exploitation
industrielle des grands fonds était à
terme le cap fixé notre débat
d'aujourd'hui
donc particulièrement bienvenu parmi les
questions qu'il soulève celle-ci est
centrale est-ce que la déclaration du
Président de la République à Lisbonne se
traduira concrètement par des actes pour
changer une donne jusqu'ici
particulièrement inquiétante une donne
inquiétante si elle devait des moucher
sur la voie conduisant à l'extraction
minière alors que ce que je retiens moi
comme trois éléments principaux des
auditions de notre mission d'information
d'abord la méconnaissance considérable
ça a été dit du fonctionnement des
écosystèmes des fonds marins des
équilibres fragiles d'absorption du
carbone par les océans
déstabiliser tout cela pourraient avoir
de très graves effets ensuite la grande
vulnérabilité des écosystèmes profonds
les impacts ravageurs des
expérimentations qui ont été menées dans
les années 70 ont montré que la
restauration de la biodiversité des
abysses est terriblement lente enfin
troisième élément une rentabilité
économique vraiment pas avérée face à
l'extraction terrestre et surtout au
potentiel de l'économie circulaire rien
que l'énergie a déployé pour remonter
des matériaux des abysses et
particulièrement rédhibitoire donc la
première mise à l'épreuve de la
déclaration de Lisbonne a été en juillet
le conseil de la IFM sur la perspective
d'un code minier on peut regretter que
la France n'est pas saisie ce moment
pour être aussi ferme que le président à
Lisbonne certains s'attendaient à ce
qu'elle renforce les tenants du
moratoire
l'échéance de la règle des deux ans
posée par l'état de nos roues approches
et déjà de nombreux États s'opposent à
l'adoption d'un règlement à horizon
juillet 2023 il préconise plutôt une
pause dans les négociations pour avoir
le temps d'entamer un travail approfondi
qui mène vers un cadre juridique solide
et protecteur de la biodiversité marine
il semble que notre pays souhaite gagner
du temps dans les négociations qui vont
conduire à l'adoption d'un code minier
le président a évoqué la conférence des
Nations Unies sur les océans de 2025
comme étant approprié il serait
raisonnable de continuer à pousser en
sens cette fameuse règle des deux ans
constitue aussi un flou juridique qui
mériterait une analyse claire bien que
la France je le sais n'interprète pas
cette règle comme une obligation pour le
Conseil d'approuver provisoirement de
manière automatique toute demande
déposée à partir de juillet 2023 cette
règle constitue une menace à ce jour en
ce qu'elle pourrait permettre
l'approbation de licence monsieur le
ministre ses ambiguïté qui persiste
doivent impérativement être clarifiés
pour engager et négociations cruciales à
l'avenir la France c'est-à-dire tous les
services et personnes en charge du sujet
sont post-elle fermement à
l'exploitation minière et
s'engage-t-elle interdire l'exploitation
minière dans les eaux territoriales
françaises d'abord la France
confirme-t-elle de façon claire son
opposition à l'adoption du Code Minier
10 juillet 2023 et s'assure à ce titre
qu'un travail collectif et robuste ou
autre prix à l'issue du délai des deux
ans dès juillet 23 la France
soutient-elle le principe que toutes les
demandes de délivrance de licence Provis
d'exploitation soit fermement rejetée en
attendant qu'un cadre réglementaire
solide et protecteur des abysses soit
adoptés enfin je termine au moment où
des problèmes de gouvernance de
transparence de l'IFM sont mises en
lumière est-il tolérable par exemple que
son opaque commission LTC autorise dans
une procédure très peu démocratique peu
transparente et absolument pas inclusive
la société canadienne TMC d'effectuer
des tests dans le Sean pour remonter
trois 3600 tonnes nodules excusez du peu
de quelle façon par quels moyens la
France oeuvre-t-elle en faveur d'une
réforme de l'IFM je vous remercie merci
cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur je
crois que vous pouvez rejoindre
l'équipe gouvernementale parce que sur
toutes les questions je vous dis oui oui
c'est ce que nous avons fait depuis plus
d'un an un travail important à la FM
comme je vous le disais pour convaincre
les les
pays qu'il faut adopter ce code qui a un
code important pour la préservation de
la Budé pour la préservation de la haute
mer et en même temps pour répondre très
clairement à votre question il n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté il y a une clarté une clarté
de dire que la France ne s'engage pas
dans la voie et ne souhaite pas
l'exploitation la foi la France pardon
s'engage dans la voie de l'exploration
de la connaissance de la recherche
scientifique et Marine et dans le même
temps nous constatons la nécessité de ne
pas laisser les eaux laisser la haute
mer au fond à la privatisation
a une forme de monopellisation pour des
activités qui seraient incontrôlées et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
partout dans toutes les instances
internationales multilatérales nous nous
battons pour faire reconnaître et pour
travailler sur un cadre contraignant et
pour répondre à votre question très
clairement aussi sur les actes entre
exploration exploitation acte numéro 1
dans les appels à projets dans France
2030 il n'y a que des projets pour
l'exploration aucun cette explicite sur
l'exploitation deuxièmement vous l'avez
évoqué aussi la France en 2022 a modifié
son code minier pour justement pas
pouvoir engager ce ce c'est pardon ces
activités cette entreprise
d'exploitation donc à la fois la France
a dit très clairement uniquement
exploration nous l'avons acté dans le
Code minier et nous nous battons à
l'international que ce soit Abbeville
engie ou au sein de laifm pour renforcer
et pour construire ce cadre légal parce
que BFM et la déclinaison en fait de la
conférence de Montego Bay et c'est le
cadre légal en tout cas le cadre que
nous avons pour l'instant pour discuter
merci Monsieur le Ministre 30 secondes
chers collègues 20 secondes oui
j'entends donc vos oui oui et votre
proposition rejoindre l'équipe
j'aurais aimé entendre la même clarté au
moment des auditions que nous avons
menées dans les mois précédents j'en
suis très content c'est de clarté ceci
dit sur la réforme de l'IFM souhaité
exprimée par la France il serait bon de
partager ces demandes nous faire
connaître dans quel sens vous souhaitez
la réformer et sur et sur cette fameuse
règle des deux ans et sur son
appréciation il serait bon aussi que
votre gouvernement partage son analyse
juridique qui serait si elle était
valide rassurante
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Michel Dennemont pour le groupe
RDPI pour 6 minutes
le Président c'est le ministre mes chers
collègues
allez vocation de cette mission
d'information qui a fourni un travail
remarquable je me suis permis à penser
au monde du silence de Louis mal
en 1956 avec ce deuxième film de
l'histoire des prises de sous-marine en
couleur nous vivions dans un contexte
naïf où le grand public découvrait une
courbe d'abondance qu'il croyait
inépuisable mais entre temps passé cet
état de Faurie nous avons déversé durant
des décennies les déchets les bouts
d'épuration et des séchés chimiques
industriels radioactif ou plastique
aujourd'hui la place de l'océan doit
être à la mesure de son rôle dans les
équilibres climatiques
environnementaux et sociaux planétaire
comme la répéter le président de la
République en février dernier lors du
sommet de Brest l'océan et la première
victime de ce que nous n'avons pas su
faire ou mal fait chez exploitation
pollution acidification
remise en danger il est donc temps de
préserver notre biodiversité et
notamment la haute mer un espace qui
commence là où s'arrête les zones
économiques exclusives des états cet
espace nous apprêtait tous il doit être
il ne doit pas être une zone non droit
nous neions pas que les discussions pour
élaborées à contraignant visant
sauvegarde et cette vaste zone qui
couvre près de la moitié de la planète
sont difficiles la ligne d'arrivée est
visible elle est apportée de signature
mais elle s'est encore évanouie le 26
août dernier à l'issue de 15 jours de
tractations difficiles au sein des
Nations Unies
parmi les sujets les plus débattus la
répartition des bénéfices possibles
issus d'exploitation des ressources de
haute mer ou industrie pharmaceutiques
chimiques et cosmétiques espérant
découvrir des molécules miraculeuses
dans le même temps nous apprenons une
société canadienne testera dans la zone
de Clipperton espace si cher à notre
collègue Phil folio un système composé
d'un prototype de collecteur de doodules
au front de la mer le risque ici c'est
de faire remonter des sédiments et
entraîner une perte de la biodiversité
et menacer des pluies de carbone
essentiels et remettent en cause les
pêcheries interdire
et d'autres espèces
le temps presse aussi le président de la
République souhaite mettre en place un
cadre légal pour arrêter l'exploitation
minière des grands fonds marins en haute
mer on doit donc continuer à s'activer
pour faire entendre cette voix
protection de la biodiversité marine
protection des océans luttent contre les
dérèglement climatiques et capture du
carbone nous savons que cette ligne
n'est pas partagée outre certaines
grandes puissances économiques
c'est toute une sphère privée qui est
engagée dans une course au fond marin
mais il n'y a aucune honte à défendre la
sobriété énergétique plutôt que de
l’épuisement de nos ressources le
réchauffement climatique et en
particulier le phénomène elnio entraîné
des blanchissements massifs des coraux
particulièrement de l'océan Indien au
Japon et dans les Caraïbes en tout
la planète a perdu 14% de ses coraux
entre 2009 et 2018
le rapport de mission de Jean-Louis levé
nous le rappelle
l'océan constitue la principale source
de protéines pour 3 milliards d'êtres
humains et fournir la moitié de
l'oxygène que nous respirons représente
l'un des principaux réservoirs de la
biodiversité dans le monde notre voie
notre devoir est donc de préserver
cette mise en garde ne doit pas occulter
notre besoin de connaissance la mission
d'information le souligne d'ailleurs
très bien si son poisson des fonds
marins ont été cartographiés par
satellite la résolution obtenue par ce
moyen inadapté au fromage et de l'ordre
du kilomètre voire de la dizaine de
kilomètres ce qui est évidemment
insuffisant pour de l'exploration fine
dit autrement il n'est pas logique qu'on
puisse faire des projets pour atteindre
Morse la lune ou fait des missions
spatiales prometteuses mais qu'on
néglige le fond marin à l'instant des
missions réalisées par Cousteau qui nous
a permis de découvrir la féerie de l'or
bleu nous devons poursuivre nos
recherches en direction de cet horizon
sans lumière en considéeux
ainsi le gouvernement constitué un
comité de pilotage ministériel celui-ci
s'est réuni à plusieurs reprises la
première session s'est tenue sous la
présidence des ministres en charge de la
VR de l'industrie et de la recherche en
février 2022 le fil directeur de ce
comité et la mobilisation de crédit
public des appels d'offres encourageant
l'exploration des fonds marins en
étroite association avec la communauté
scientifique la dynamique est enclenchée
nous devons la poursuivre monsieur le
ministre
pourriez-vous nous expliquer le but de
ce comité
va-t-il être réuni à nouveau
participer de la volonté de la France de
la Croatie connaissance scientifiques
sur les grands fonds marins je vous
remercie pour votre attention merci
chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur d'abord je partage
ce que vous avez parfaitement explicité
sur le fait de retrouver au fond le fil
de l'aventure maritime suscité
d'évocations et puis faire naître
partout sur nos territoires notamment à
la réunion des futurs scientifiques des
futurs chercheurs des explorateurs qui
vont contribuer à mieux connaître nos
océans pour répondre très précisément à
cette question vous avez raison ce qui
me permet de peut-être clarifier la
gouvernance aussi de ces enjeux de
grands fonds marins j'ai réuni avec Miss
de l'industrie le ministre de la
Recherche l'enseignement supérieur un
comité
de pilotage des grands fonds marins il
avait comme objectif à la fois de faire
le point sur la mission numéro une
mission qui a eu lieu à Mayotte et puis
surtout de lancer l'appel à projet de 25
millions d'euros sur les grands fonds
marins je vais ici expliciter quelle
était la nature et qu'elle sera la
nature de ce de cet appel à projet de 25
millions d'euros c'est pour financer des
projets de recherche de développement
pour construire des équipements des
drones des navires et notamment
travailler sur leur autonomie et donc il
s'agira avec cet appel à projet de 25
millions d'euros de développer des
sous-systèmes des capteurs des
composantes adaptés à ce milieu marin
mais aussi des logiciels et des
traitements de données nous avons à
l'occasion aussi de ce comité de
pilotage de grands fonds marins annoncé
un programme d'équipement prioritaire de
recherche comme des drones et quatre
missions exploratoires scientifiques
sont prévues de cartographies d'analyse
de l'activité sismique du volcan de
Mayotte d'un drone scientifique et d'un
robot d'intervention vous le voyez ce
comité de pilotage de l'objectif numéro
10 de France 2030 avait un triple
objectif d'abord réunir toutes les
parties prenantes tous les ministères
des ambassadeurs ils sont nombre de 6
tous les acteurs de cette belle mission
deuxièmement faire le point tirer les
leçons de ce qui a été fait depuis déjà
quelques années et puis de redire qu'il
faut donner à la France aux chercheurs
aux scientifiques à tous nos organismes
de recherche comme notamment le CNRS ou
les frères les moyens de faire de la
France une puissance scientifique et
donc le prochain se réunira au début de
l'année prochaine pour continuer à faire
le point et continuer à porter cette
dynamique je vous remercie merci
Monsieur le Ministre la parole est à
Madame Angèle Préville pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste républicain pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le président de la Mission mes chers
collègues l'humanité a dépassé les
limites de la capacité de charge de la
planète et s'aventure toujours plus loin
en territoire non durable voilà ce que
dit aujourd'hui dans le journal
Libération Jurgen renders professeur
émérite de stratégie climatiques à Oslo
un des auteurs du fameux rapport medows
ce rapport intitulé les limites de la
croissance publiées en 1972 il y a 50
ans déjà alors que nous commençons tout
juste à agir dressait le constat
alarmant de la croissance exponentielle
physique dans un monde fini en effet la
quantité de ressources naturelles
utilisée par personne et par an dans le
monde est toujours en croissance et
c'est ce que j'appelle la croissance
physique de fait 6 des 9 limites
planétaires ont déjà été dépassés nous
habitons à monde qui se dégrade sans
cesse allons-nous refaire les mêmes
erreurs dans les abysses comme nous
l'avons fait sur car une extraction ne
peut se faire sans dommage collatéral
l'exploitation impacte forcément
l'environnement est présente des risques
non négligeables pour les êtres vivants
habitants les profondeurs coraux d'eau
froide crabes
anémone transparente ce sont des
écosystèmes uniques plongés dans
l'obscurité où l'on trouve ces espèces
endémiques les abysses abritent ainsi
une grande diversité biologique que nous
nous faisons contrevoir et qui promet de
superbes découvertes mais notre mode de
vie implique une consommation de plus en
plus forte de métaux et de terres rares
et induits une utilisation importante
d'appareils numériques de véhicules
électriques le développement
indispensable des énergies renouvelables
face aux défis énergétiques va
nécessiter une consommation accrue de
ses ressources face à ces deux enjeux
contradictoires préservés et produire
une sensibilisation du grand public
devient une nécessité afin d'atténuer la
pression qui s'exerce sur la recherche
de nouveaux gisements et justement les
grand fond océanique sont riches en
ressources minérales et l'état actuel du
monde nous montre bien la nécessité
d'être plus indépendant puisque
aujourd'hui la majorité des métaux
viennent de Chine trois types de
minéralisation sont connus à ce jour
nodules polymétaliques encrûtement
cobaltifères et amas sulfuris toutes ces
richesses suscitent de plus en plus de
convoitises c'est pourquoi l'autorité
internationale des fonds marins doit
être conforté avec plus de transparence
dans sa gouvernance mais surtout dans
son rôle de contrôle pour la
préservation des écosystèmes
actuellement seulement 1% cela a déjà
été dit de la haute mer fait l'objet
d'une protection juridique et il faudra
aller plus loin car c'est un bien commun
sur notre continent des pays comme la
Norvège que nous avons visité avec la
mission on les giférait pour autoriser
dans un avenir proche l'exploitation des
grands fonds marins cette exploitation
industrielle
extraction de minerai sera une nouvelle
atteinte au vivant destruction du milieu
habitat et phone mise en suspension de
sédiments et de particules métalliques
vibrations provoquant des impacts
acoustiques perturbations lumineuses
puisqu'on est dans des zones de grande
obscurité ce que je viens de mentionner
constituera à minima l'impact des
extractions minières or l'océan produit
plus de la moitié du dioxygène de l'air
fixe le carbone et constitue d'ailleurs
un prodigieux puis de carbone et cela
uniquement grâce au vivant qui s'y
trouve or le vivant il est menacé par le
réchauffement vous le savez les
pollutions diverses et variées chimiques
plastiques sonores qui sont provoqués
par l'homme à titre d'exemple lorsque
nous faisons un prélèvement scientifique
en milieu marin on peut en voir les
traces des années plus tard ce qui est
détruit ne se reconstituera pas avant
des dizaines d'années car ces
écosystèmes se régénèrent bien moins
vite que sur terre pour autant la
recherche je dois tout soutenu et
encouragé la France doit se doter comme
le souligne le rapport d'une filière
scientifique marine de premier plan
puisque nous disposons du deuxième
domaine maritime mondial cela est
valable pour l'Ifremer et dont il faut
accroître les moyens mais aussi pour le
CNRS dans lequel 2000 scientifiques
travaillent sur le monde marin et bien
sûr le chôm en effet nous devons avoir
les moyens de garantir notre
souveraineté et la sûreté de nos données
numériques qui transitent par les câbles
sous-marins sans compter que nos
territoires d'outre-mer ne sont parfois
reliés que par un câble face au risque
géopolitiques nous devons maintenir
voire même renforcer les capacités
françaises d'intervention dans les
grands fonds la découverte des abysses
soulève le voile sur un monde fabuleux
emblématique de ce qu'est la beauté du
monde foisonnante inattendue et pour
finir magnifique il paraît que chaque
prélèvement
révèle des dizaines d'espèces nouvelles
le seul fait de savoir cela et d'une
certaine manière réconfortant la France
sera-t-elle active à l'intern nationale
pour œuvrer à la préservation de la
haute mer en particulier je remercie le
rapporteur et le président pour cette
mission très riche et le formidable
travaille accompli merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur président madame
la sénatrice
dans votre intervention vous avez dit
beaucoup de choses sur beaucoup de
plantes et d'autres choses que j'ai déjà
indiqué donc je vais éviter de me
répéter vu l'heure tardive enfin
peut-être que pour les débats
parlementaires c'est quasiment tôt vous
dire peut-être sur trois sujets que vous
avez abordés qui sont nouveaux dans le
débat qui sont pour moi essentiels je
crois pour nous ici aussi le premier sur
la sensibilisation de nos concitoyens
notamment des plus jeunes publics c'est
un enjeu important à la fois pour
continuer à avoir un élan collectif sur
une plus grande protection de nos océans
de la biodiversité marine je crois aussi
pour attirer un certain nombre de jeunes
dans les métiers de la mer et de dire
que les métiers de la mer sont parfois
méconnus mal connues font l'objet au
fond d'une vision dépassée et qu'il y a
là une pluralité
pluridiscipénarité que ce soit géologie
océanographie économie aussi l'enjeu
entre le littoral et la mer
bien évidemment d'arriver à connecter
tout ça avec les nouveaux enjeux pardon
de câbles sous-marins de surveillance de
protection et d'autonomie stratégique et
donc la sensibilisation des publics les
plus jeunes en fonction aussi de ce
qu'est la réalité des territoires on
parle pas de la mer de la même manière
dans un territoire que vous connaissez
bien qui connaît très bien ces enjeux
dans un autre où l'accès à la mer est
quand même beaucoup plus éloigné et donc
c'est pour cela que dans le cadre de
France 2030 nous avons financé une
mission en milieu de l'Atlantique c'est
un tournage qui a été réalisé avec des
journalistes des documentaristes qui
justement a pour but de vulgariser ses
enjeux de mieux les faire comprendre
pour que chacun comprenne aussi les
enjeux de la consommation que l'on fait
au quotidien notamment dans tous les
outils électriques électroniques et de
dire que dans chacun de nos téléphones
portables dans chacun de nos objets qui
nous permettent parfois de voir des
magnifiques images de l'océan l'espace
de deux clics ou de deux sweat et bien
ça un impact sur les océans ça un impact
sur la biodiversité et à journée ça a
été chercher ça fait l'objet d'une
exploitation et donc il faut qu'on soit
particulièrement vigilant pour être
sobre pour réduire et pour éviter
d'avoir un impact sur la biodiversité
marine merci merci Monsieur le Ministre
pas de réplique la parole est Madame
Nassima Dada pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 4 minutes
monsieur les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues parler des grands fonds marins
en France et pour la France reste ce
soir une grande question alors même
qu'une bonne politique de protection et
d'exploitation de notre potentiel
maritime pourrait être pour notre nation
une solution mes collègues rapportum
Michel Canevet riches ne citron pas dans
leur rapport d'information dont nous
débattons ce soir quand il parle de faux
départ depuis de nombreuses années pas
le vôtre puisque je pense que vous
prenez un très bon départ monsieur le
ministre en vous écoutant depuis tout à
l'heure de faux départ ou de gouvernance
éclaté entravant la dynamique nécessaire
à une vision politique des fonds marins
en France car il est toujours utile de
préciser que la France est la deuxième
puissance maritime mondiale après les
États-Unis on l'a dit avant moi comme il
est toujours utile de préciser et de
rappeler que 97,5 % de notre Zee sont
liés aux grammaire et reste pourtant
dans l'ombre des collectivités
territoriales que nous sommes à la
Réunion à Mayotte la Polynésie de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon même de la
Guyane il est toujours utile de rappeler
que le potentiel économique géopolitique
de nos îles épars dans l'Indien Océanie
est important grâce à la ze dont dispose
la France dans le canal de Mozambique à
proximité de la frite les 20
recommandations émises par mes collègues
donne donc un nouvel élan à la stratégie
nationale telle que souhaitée par de
nombreuses
autorités auditionnées et ses
propositions vont dans le bon sens je me
permettrai seulement d'en souligner deux
principales
écosystème à préserver a dit mon
collègue à souligner les autres
collègues ce le volet de la préservation
je crois que nous avons beaucoup avancé
dans nos îles épars nous avons même
sanctuarisé les terres jusqu'à abattre
16000 vaches chez les îles Saint-Paul et
Amsterdam et il est question aujourd'hui
d'abattre les reines qui peuplent les
îles Kerguelen donc envie de vous dire
ce soir que nous pouvons continuer à
gérer de façon durable la faune et la
flore de ces régions sans devenir des
ayatollas de l'écologie et cela vaut
pour les fonds marins également car il
nous faut allier la présence humaine et
la préservation de l'environnement dans
nos îles Vierges j'ai presque envie de
dire ces
îles vierges de l'océan Indien je parle
des îles épars bien évidemment vous
l'aurez compris qui reste des
territoires d'expérimentation
particulièrement pertinent une autre
région maritime de la France à côté de
la Bretagne sa collègue l'information
donc avec la population environnante
avec les élus avec les collectivités
territoriales restent primordial au cœur
d'une mobilisation intelligente et
partagée qui faciliterait
l'acceptabilité sociale des populations
impactées aussi nombreux sont les élus
qui demandent une coordination entre par
exemple la Réunion et Mayotte sur une
vision partagée des fonds marins en
matière environnementale comment matière
économique et au-delà au niveau de la
COI quand on parle de la COI je crois
qu'il nous faut aussi quand on aborde ce
sujet
aborder celui de la coopération
régionale avec les pays voisins les pays
de la COI avec également la grande île
qui est Madagascar
s'agissant des énergies marines un
centre de recherche existe aujourd'hui à
la Réunion les travaux sont menés par
l'Ifremer l'IRD mais quel partage pour
assurer l'implication des pouvoirs
publics des collectivités territoriales
et je pense également aux communes
littorales qui sont nombreuses sur nos
îles en clair vous l'aurez compris les
ressources de l'océan profond leur
utilisation durable au service d'une
prospérité commune ainsi que
l'implication de toutes parties
prenantes dans les choix éventuels en
matière d'exploration ou d'exploitation
des grands fonds marins ne doit pas se
décider en vase clos mais de manière
concertée et élargi je pense que la
France il prend vraiment le bon chemin
et et principalement au niveau des
recherches en lien avec l'ensemble des
Outre-mer mais aussi les pays
limitrophes je pense par exemple à
l'Australie dans le domaine des
Géosciences Marines le deuxième point
sur lequel je souhaiterais attirer
l'attention du ministre et celui de
l'état de la flotte outre-mer et la
dotation en drone sous-marin mais vous
avez quasiment répondu à la question le
rapport note la nécessité d'accourir des
patrouilles à grands fonds des
patrouilleurs grands fonds en lien avec
l'industrie française là dessus vous
nous avez aussi
livré que d'ici 2025 nous aurons 6
patrouilleurs dont deux à la Réunion et
je mens réjouis je pense que je peux et
que nous pouvons compter sur votre
implication en tous les cas au ministère
de la mer les outre-mer attendent
beaucoup de votre travail en lien avec
nous-mêmes on vous remercions merci cher
collègue
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice merci beaucoup vous avez là
aussi dit beaucoup de choses à la fois
sur la stratégie puis la nécessité
d'impliquer c'est à la fois la vision et
puis la méthode d'abord vous dire et là
nous devons reconnaître en tout cas le
gouvernement doit reconnaître qu'on doit
aller beaucoup plus loin sur la
stratégie que vous avez évoqué
un dos
Océanie c'est bien comme ça que nous
devons dire on a fait depuis 5 ans un
travail je crois approfondie en lien
avec les différentes collectivités
locales sur la stratégie Indo-Pacifique
je crois que nous devons entamer et
faire le même travail sur la stratégie
indocelli en lien bien évidemment avec
tous les autres territoires tous les
autres pays et donc je vous invite là
aussi à travailler avec nous en tout cas
nous nous impliquerons pour faire en
sorte de développer une stratégie et une
vision ensuite vous avez parlé au fond
de la force des territoires pour
réfléchir à tous ces enjeux ces enjeux
de valorisation ces enjeux aussi de
souveraineté alimentaire puisque quand
vous êtes à la Réunion l'océan est aussi
un enjeu fondamental pour l'autonomie
alimentaire et donc la nécessité la
capacité aussi à moderniser la flotte je
sais que c'est quelque chose que vous
portez que nous allons continuer de
porter avec notamment le ministre des
outre-mer et donc l'invitation que je
vous fais la proposition c'est dans le
cadre de ce que j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure sur la planification des grands
fonds marins et bien de puiser dans la
force de ces territoires dans les
spécificités et sur votre connaissance
aussi de cet espace pour à la fois
travailler sur la valorisation sur la
protection sur la parfois
sanctuarisation et puis sur la
déclinaison d'une coopération régionale
vous parliez de
parler du Mozambique on peut parler bien
évidemment des états de la COI et donc
on va entamer ce travail dans le cadre
aussi du Conseil national de la mère et
du littoral on va aboutir de manière je
crois
raisonnable c'est à dire d'ici l'été
2023 à ces stratégie qui se basera sur
la force des territoires comme celui de
la réunion je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Madame Muriel jourdat pour le groupe
les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
mission d'information monsieur le
rapporteur mes premiers mots seront bien
évidemment pour notre collègue Teva
rofritch qui a été rapporteur de ce
travail sur une meilleure maîtrise des
fonds marins fondara dont l'importance
n'est plus à démontrer je crois que les
événements récents sur nos stream nous
rappelle que les fonds marins c'est le
lieu du transport des hydrocarbures
c'est aussi le lieu où 98% des échanges
numériques et des informations
numériques circulent et puis c'est aussi
le lieu où peuvent se trouver les
minerais les métaux dont nous avons
besoin aujourd'hui dans notre industrie
notamment c'est évidemment sur ce sujet
que notre rapport s'est attardé et c'est
aussi sur ce sujet que je m'attarderai
cette question particulière évidemment
ce hurt à plusieurs obstacles qui ont
été tous révélés par ce rapport
d'information le premier bien sûr c'est
celui de la connaissance la biodiversité
n'est connue qu'à hauteur de 5% dans ses
fonds marins et si cela ne doit pas être
en obstacle total à leur exploitation il
faut être évidemment vigilant et nous ne
pouvons pas exploiter sans mieux
connaître cette biodiversité nous ne
pouvons pas non plus exploiter sans
mieux connaître ses fonds eux-mêmes les
connaissances bathymétriques portent sur
deux à 5% du plancher océanique et à la
vitesse à laquelle nous allons et bien
il nous faudrait 3500 ans pour les
connaître totalement il est donc
nécessaire de se doter des moyens
suffisants de se doter des moyens
suffisants certains ont été très
largement précisés par mes prédécesseurs
et je n'y reviens pas mais il s'agit
bien sûr des moyens à nous organismes
publics je pense à
Ifremer au CNRS au chom bien sûr au
bergm et l'idée également mais il s'agit
également de nos entreprises privées qui
ont un rôle à jouer qui sont nombreuses
mais qui manque un peu de leadership et
qui manque surtout de visibilité
politique il faut le dire j'ai bien
entendu monsieur le ministre que vous
indiquez à quel point le président de la
République était impliqué mais notre
rapport a révélé qu'il n'y avait pas
moins de 8 ministères qui étaient en
charge de ces stratégies huit ministères
donc aucun d'un véritable leadership en
tout cas pas le ministère de la mer
malheureusement nous l'aurions souhaité
nous avons à côté de ces ministères le
secrétariat général de la mer
effectivement et vous nous indiquerez en
quoi la nomination de Didier l'allemand
est un signe positif pour cette
stratégie maritime mais je devrais dire
pour ces stratégies maritimes car en
réalité cohabitent plusieurs stratégies
ce qui a été aussi révélée par le
rapport bien sûr plus on investissement
en France 2030 mais également les 6
mères les comités interministériels de
la mer et la stratégie des fonds marins
également du ministère des armées dont
on a eu quelques difficultés à
comprendre comment ils s'interpénétrait
de la même façon qu'on a eu quelques
difficultés à comprendre si les
financements se cumulaient ne se
cumulaient pas mais nous vous nous avez
donné un chiffre un chiffre tout à
l'heure et au-delà de cette volonté
politique mais ça c'est inscrit aussi
dans la volonté politique il a été
rappelé que 97% de notre zone économique
exclusive se situe dans les territoires
ultramarins et les auditions auxquelles
nous avons procédé des élus ultramarins
ont tout révélé à quel point ils ont eu
le sentiment et ce n'était pas qu'un
sentiment à vrai dire à quel point ils
n'ont pas été concertés en aucune façon
sur ce qui se passait sur leur
territoire et alors que on l'a indiqué
tout à l'heure culturellement et bien la
mère peut confiner au sacré dans
certains territoires il ne paraît pas
envisageable de travailler sans eux mais
je crois que vous l'avez parfaitement
saisi monsieur le ministre voilà donc
quels sont les obstacles qu'elles sont
les enjeux et ne nous y trompons pas il
ne s'agit pas de trouver au fond de la
mer des minerais dont nous manquerions
sur terre car aussi le rapport a révélé
que plus nous avons besoin des minerais
et plus nous en trouvons sur terre la
situation n'est pas celle là l'enjeu est
véritablement celui de la souveraineté
sur des territoires et dans des domaines
où nos compétiteurs sont nombreux et
sont agressifs il ne suffit pas de dénir
une zone économique exclusive de 11
millions de kilomètres carrés encore
faut-il avoir la volonté de refaire de
la France une grande puissance maritime
et je crois que nous avons tous les
atouts pour cela je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice merci beaucoup pour
de votre intervention qui me permet de
clarifier un certain nombre de choses
notamment sur la question de la
gouvernance
et je souscris pleinement à vos propos
sur la nécessité au fond de faire de la
France de continuer à faire de la France
une puissance maritime qui ne s'arrête
pas simplement à l'enjeu de l'espace de
la délimitation qui est d'abord un enjeu
aussi de puissance économique de
puissance militaire et de puissance
scientifiques comme je l'ai rappelé
le cadre est au fond la gouvernance elle
est très claire je vais essayer ici de
l'expliciter il y a la mer c'est un
espace et donc étant donné que c'est un
espace il y a plusieurs activités qui
s'y jouent et donc il y a plusieurs
secteurs et donc il y a plusieurs
ministères et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons avancé ou en tout
cas nous avons déterminé que la
meilleure manière de prendre en compte
cette interministérialité de la mer et
de faire des enjeux maritimes un enjeu
écologique un enjeu stratégique et aussi
un enjeu de souveraineté c'était de le
placer auprès de la première ministre et
donc il y a le cimer qui est un cadre
politique le comité intermittel de la
mer qui est présidé par la première mise
ou se font les grandes orientations de
la politique de la mer ensuite il y a
une déclinaison politique c'est votre
serviteur le secrétaire d'État à la mer
qui coordonne politiquement tout ce qui
se passe sur la mer c'est ce qu'on devra
faire sur la planification maritime pour
les énergies marines renouvelables qu'on
doit faire en lien avec bien évidemment
le ministère des armées qu'on doit faire
en lien avec le monde de la pêche et
donc donc sur les enjeux que vous
évoquez dans le cadre de la stratégie il
y a une instance qui s'appelle le
Conseil national de la mère et du
littoral qui au fond le Parlement de la
mer qui regroupe des parlementaires qui
regroupent des usagers qui regroupent
des associations et qui là aussi est
placé sous l'autorité du secrétaire
d'État de la mer et qui a la comme
objectif de faire cette coordination et
puis il y a à côté le secrétariat
général de la mer qu'il a fait la
coordination administrative
administrative pas l'animation politique
pas l'impulsion politique et donc voyez
c'est clair il y a le cimer il y a le
secrétaire d'État à la mer et il y a
pour la partie administrative et la
déclinaison partout sur les territoires
en lien avec les préfets et les préfets
maritimes le secrétaire général à la mer
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
il y a pas de réplique
je ne suis pas sûr que vous explications
est apportée beaucoup de clarté elles
ont en tout cas démontré que il y a
beaucoup d'acteurs et qu'on peine à
comprendre malheureusement quel est leur
articulation réelle
merci Monsieur Jean-Michel Houlgate pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste
républicain pour 4 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues comme de
nombreux orateurs précédents l'ont
mentionné les océans présentent des
potentiels inégalés dans le domaine
nutritionnel pharmacologique et que
l'énergétique minier certains s'emploi à
dire que la vie serait issue des océans
et qu'aujourd'hui notre survie en
dépendrait pourvu que nous sachions
exploiter ces ressources de façon
raisonnée ils font aussi l'objet
d'enjeux stratégique et géopolitique et
les conflits terrestres trouvent
désormais leur prolongation dans les
fonds marins le rapport qui sert de base
au débat de ce soir insiste sur la
nécessité d'une cohérence dans la
stratégie et d'une coordination des
actions mais au-delà de la gouvernance
se pose la question de savoir si la
France a l'ambition de devenir une
grande nation maritime elle devra comme
le mentionne Christian Buchet
s'affranchir de son passé qui
constituait à vouloir desserrer la
mâchoire de fer de Charles Quint et à se
tourner vers l'est donc vers la terre
l'exposition miroir du monde que l'on
peut admirer en ce moment au Musée du
Luxembourg témoigne que la connaissance
et la puissance ont dépendu de la
maîtrise des mères et de l'organisation
des circuits logistiques comme l'ont
fait les Portugais les Hollandais les
Anglais et aujourd'hui les Chinois
affirmer une vocation maritime c'est
impulsée une identité maritime qui passe
par la sensibilisation l'éducation la
vulgarisation scientifique et technique
la constitution d'un réseau de formation
et de recherche la création d'un pôle
d'excellence permettant de structurer
une filière industrielle dont l'amorçage
ne pourra être effectué comme le
souligne le rappeur dans un premier
temps que par la commande publique
je voudrais souligner les efforts des
villes et des régions qui aujourd'hui en
France ont lancé de nombreuses
initiatives ainsi à Cherbourg de l'autre
côté du Couesnon en Normandie qui est la
5 départements la Cité de la Mer qui
vient d'être élu monument préféré des
Français 2022 accueille en cette fin de
semaine ainsi que événementiel dénommé
grands océans et cela organisé par
Science et Avenir et et les échos alors
monsieur le ministre au moment où la
récente nomination du secrétaire général
de la mer nous interroge quelle est
votre feuille de route quels seront les
prochaines actions que vous impulserez
pour structurer une véritable filière
océanique sur le plan international
l'exploration et l'exploitation des
fonds marins prennent l'allure d'une
ruée vers l'or bleu et cela au détriment
de la préservation de l'environnement
ainsi au-delà des recommandations du
rapport le groupe socialiste écologiste
et républicain du Sénat ainsi sur la
nécessité de soutenir une initiative
diplomatique visant à promouvoir au
niveau international laboratoire sur
l'exploitation minière des fonds marins
n'excluant pas la possibilité
d'intervention pour l'exploration qui
devront être néanmoins codifiées afin de
ne pas détruire les écosystèmes de
mettre en place des sanctuaires des
profondeurs afin de délimiter des zones
qui seraient totalement protégés et qui
pourraient être reliés entre elles par
des corridors biologiques sous-marins il
est à noter que cette proposition figure
dans l'étude les grands fonds marins
quel choix stratégiques pour l'avenir de
l'humanité réalisé par la fondation de
la mer en 2022 et enfin de refondre
complètement l'autorité internationale
des fonds marins et notamment révisé son
mode de financement basé actuellement
sur une taxe perçue sur l'exploitation
qui positionne de ce fait l'autorité
dans une situation ambiguë
cette refonte doit aussi permettre à
l'autorité de contrôler et de
sanctionner les pays et les acteurs qui
controviendraient aux obligations de
protection de la biodiversité de la
biodiversité alors monsieur le ministre
le gouvernement partage-t-il l'analyse
de refonder la IFM son mode de
financement et de lui donner un pouvoir
de contrôle et de sanction
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur merci de toutes ces questions
très vastes qui vont des objectifs
politiques jusque à la question de la FM
pour répondre très rapidement le plus
concrètement possible d'abord l'objectif
de ce secrétariat d'État la feuille de
route qui a été donnée tourne autour de
3 objectifs le premier la protection des
océans et de la biodiversité marine à la
fois sur le territoire mais aussi à
l'international c'est tout l'objet de ce
que l'on porte aussi dans le cadre de
bbnj deuxièmement c'est développer
l'économie maritime partout sur nos
territoires lancer la décarbonation de
ce secteur notamment les ports et les
navires et soutenir notre modèle de
pêche qu'un modèle de pêche très
diverses que ça va de la Méditerranée
jusqu'à à la Manche et puis le troisième
enjeu de troisième objectif c'est de
planifier de lancer cette grande
exercice de planification de l'espace
maritime parce qu'on le voit bien la mer
est un objet au fond où se multiplient
les usages où il y a une densification
et une multiplication et entre les
énergies marines renouvelables entre les
pêcheurs ou encore dans les activités
plutôt touristiques il y a besoin
d'avoir cette plan et donc sur le
deuxième point le point que vous m'avez
interrogé sur la planification et la
sanctuarisation pardon c'est cet
exercice de planification qui va nous
permettre là de répondre à l'objectif
qui a été proposé par la fondation de la
mer de la sanctuarisation et dans la
stratégie nationale de biodiversité nous
pouvons aller vers cette sanctuarisation
j'y suis favorable le Gouvernement est
favorable avancer et on aura besoin de
ce cadre de planification en lien avec
les territoires et puis sur le dernier
point le troisième qui est celui de la
IFM oui nous sommes favorables à une
réforme du financement de la IFM nous
sommes favorables à au fond adapté
l'organisation le cadre de l'IFM aux
nouveaux enjeux et nouvelles demandes à
la réalité qui est celui et bien de
protéger les fonds marins d'avoir un
cadre international qui permette bien de
protéger nos océans et donc nous allons
avancer nous aurons besoin des débats
parlementaires pour continuer d'avancer
mais je sais que vous y êtes prêt comme
le rapporteur comme les différentes
orateurs qui étaient ici avant vous je
vous remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
pas de la parole est à Monsieur François
bonhomme pour le groupe des Républicains
pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur mes chers
collègues d'abord je vous saluer ici
l'initiative du groupe RDP et
l'organisation de ce débat qui nous
permet effectivement de mettre en
exergue la situation dans notre pays du
point de vue maritime l'espace maritime
de la France dans les domaines
économiques mais aussi militaires est un
élément constitutif fort de notre
capacité d'influencer plus largement ne
sa puissance cette mission d'information
nous rappelle fort à propos que notre
zone économique exclusive est source
d'immenses richesses qu'il nous faut
protéger
protéger pour une raison économique
puisque la quasi-totalité de nos
échanges transitent par des voies
maritimes et la totalité ou presque de
nos données Internet passe par des
câbles sous-marins dont nous prenons
conscience depuis quelques temps combien
notre sécurité en dépend interromper ses
flux et notre vie individuelle et
collective en sera complètement
bouleversé et désorganisé c'est
impératif met un exergue le rôle premier
de protection de sécurisation notre
marine nationale que j'obtiens ici à
saluer de manière plus générale
l'approche maritime de notre puissance
est donc essentielle pour des raisons
multiples c'est pourquoi les
orientations stratégiques et les
capacités de la respecter sont
particulièrement importantes pour peu
que nous voulions conserver une capacité
de puissance à l'échelle de la planète
ou tout au moins conforté notre rôle
notre position de puissance régionale de
premier plan
car ces dernières années un certain
nombre de signes nous laisse penser que
notre zone influence a eu tendance à se
réduire au regard de ces d'autres
grandes puissances maritimes c'est
d'autant plus de mangeable que nous
disposons de ressources considérables je
pense bien évidemment au grand fonds
marins certes ils ont figuré dans le
plan d'investissement de France de mites
or cette mission d'information nous
rappelle combien les enjeux ont été
parfois insuffisamment partagés pourquoi
ainsi se limiter à quelques experts sous
la houlette de l'État pour fixer des
grandes orientations les moyens adéquats
nous rapportons bien souligné combien
nous avions besoin d'un pays d'un
pilotage clair et élargi c'est pourquoi
par exemple la désignation d'un délégué
intermissant le fond marin en charge
d'animer la politique des fonds marins
de coordonnées d'action des différents
ministères et les acteurs scientifiques
et véritablement nécessaire de même le
rapporteur appel de ses vœux à juste
titre la création d'un ministère de la
merde ne pas exercice pour mettre en
oeuvre la politique maritime française a
commencé par les grands fonds marins
mais de la pêche et la co-culture enfin
pourquoi ne pas impliquer le Parlement
en désignant en présentant de chaque
assemblée au sein de du comité de
pilotage de la stratégie il y a associé
les délégations parlementaires aux
outre-mer ainsi que les exécutifs
ultramarins enfin nous comptons sur vous
pour que l'on dispose de l'ensemble des
connaissances préalables avant toute
décision de prospection et
d'exploitation des ressources minières
des fonds marins elle constitue une
option sans nul doute stratégique mais
c'est à bon droit que le rapporteur ont
indiqué combien nous avons besoin de
connaissances scientifiques approfondies
qui font aujourd'hui parfois défaut sur
les grands fonds et leur écosystème
alors monsieur le ministre pour éviter
toute procrastination faites en sorte
d'écouter le Sénat au moment où tant
d'autres puissances maritimes convoite
de manière de moins en moins voilée ces
espaces nous avons des échos de ce qui
se passe dans le Pacifique et ne peuvent
que nous inquiéter à cet égard ou
l'implication des États-Unis où les
manœuvres de la Chine sont de moins en
moins feutrés il est véritablement temps
de réagir ce travail d'approfondissement
de nos connaissances et d'élargissement
des partenariats avec les partis
prenantes qui soient les chercheurs
associations élus ou entreprises et
véritablement une étape préalable avant
de considérer l'opportunité de
poursuivre ou non l'objectif d'une
exploration en vue d'une exploitation
industrielle de nos fonds marins voilà
Monsieur ministre les conditions et
l'étape indispensable pour donner
j'espère un nouveau départ à la
stratégie nationale pour les grands
fonds marins
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
si beaucoup monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur
ma présence ici et le débat qu'on nous
avons eu je crois que vous êtes au
dernier orateur qui a un débat riche
montre à quel point le gouvernement non
seulement écoute mais il va faire sienne
un certain nombre de propositions je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure notamment sur
l'application des élus des élus des
territoires
ultramarins sur cette nécessité comme
vous l'avez évoqué d'avoir une
planification stratégique notamment avec
des objectifs de sanctuarisation ou
encore de renforcer
l'interministérialité de renforcer et
bien la cohérence la convergence des
différentes stratégies et donc nous
allons vous écouter nous avons écouté
sur par exemple l'enjeu de mieux prendre
en compte ce qui a été dit et ce qui est
dit par les parlementaires c'est pour ça
que j'ai relancé dès la semaine dernière
le Conseil national de la mère et du tal
j'insiste parce que c'est le Parlement
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure tous les
acteurs c'est là où se réunissent tous
les acteurs c'est là où on définit la
stratégie c'est là où on fait
l'évaluation c'est là où se place la
concertation alors peut-être qu'il est
pas assez connu en tout cas il est très
utile c'est il me semble en plus quelque
chose qui a été porté au du Grenelle de
la mer par tous les acteurs et donc je
veux vraiment en faire le lieu où tous
les acteurs se rassemblent discutent et
surtout avancent éco-construise et puis
au Parlement je crois que ici au Sénat
le fait que vous ayez ce débat qu'on
continuera à avoir ce débat je me tiens
à votre disposition pour continuer
d'avancer à la fois sur les
investissements travailler sur la
déclinisation territoire par territoire
et puis travailler sur les moyens que
l'on doit se donner dans le cadre
notamment du PLF pour le CNRS pour
l'Ifremer pour l'IRD ou encore pour la
flotte
océanographique française et puis nous
avons et nous allons vous écouter sur
l'enjeu au fond d'avoir une personne qui
continue pas simplement de coordonner
mais d'être dans la déclinaison et dans
l'écriture territoire par territoire de
ce qui est fait et c'est pour ça que
j'ai proposé la création au sein de mon
ministère de ce poste de coordinateur de
la planification des grands fonds marins
qui fera ce travail avec tous les
ministères et qui aura pour notamment
rôle principal en tout cas pour une des
missions principales d'écouter ce que
dit Parlement d'écouter ce que dit le
Sénat et ensuite de le décliner en
action très concrète je vous remercie
merci Monsieur le Ministre pas de
réplique alors monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole pour 5 minutes pour
conclure le débat avant que le président
de la mission d'information Michel
Canevet ne prennent la parole aussi pour
5 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs d'abord merci
beaucoup pour ces riches échanges merci
de me donner la possibilité de donner la
possibilité à ceux qui nous regardent de
pouvoir échanger discuter avancer sur
cet enjeu passionnant qui est celui des
abysses et des grands fonds marins comme
vous l'avez dit les maires et les océans
couvrent 71% de la planète et la grande
majorité sont des nommés les grands
fonds avec une profondeur entre 200 et
6000 mètres et il couvre 65% du globe
vous le savez la France de par son
histoire de par sa géographie et ses
territoires ultramarins est une grande
puissance maritime et l'objectif du
président de la République et de la
feuille de route qui m'a été confiée par
la première ministre et de tout faire
pour protéger nos escients pour
valoriser nos espaces maritimes et de
faire de la France une puissance du 21e
siècle une puissance maritime qui a des
actions exemplaires sur son territoire
mais aussi à l'international être une
puissance maritime mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs ce n'est pas uniquement
est une puissance militaire ce n'est pas
uniquement est une puissance économique
c'est je le crois profondément et on l'a
vu ici et votre rapport la parfaitement
montré c'est peut-être une puissance
scientifique et donc se donner les
moyens d'avoir une stratégie pour la
recherche marine car comme vous avez pu
le voir et le décrire parfaitement
durant votre travaux la connaissance des
grands fonds marins et la condition
indispensable pour en mesurer tous leurs
effets pour mesurer ce qu'il recouvre
les valoriser mesurer la fragilité et
une fine et les protéger alors nous
avons un comité interministériel de la
mer en janvier 2021 celui-ci a fait de
l'exploration scientifique des grands
fonds marins sa priorité et comme vous
l'avez dit nous n'en connaissons qu'une
infitar ils sont moins connus que
l'espace et donc nous avons posé ici un
premier cadre et ce comité intermittaire
de la mer s'inscrit dans une
architecture dans une gouvernance et je
sais ici qu'elle a pu faire l'objet d'un
certain nombre de questions qui est pour
nous très clair il y a la première
ministre il y a le secrétaire d'État à
la mer et puis ensuite il y a une
coordination que nous faisons que je
fais en lien avec le secrétaire général
de la mer
d'ailleurs la même chose sur les enjeux
de défense nous avons un ministre de la
Défense un secret de Saria général de la
Défense nationale c'est la même chose
sur l'Europe nous avons un ministre de
légué à l'Europe et puis nous avons un
secrétaire général aux Affaires
européennes qui permettent de faire
cette coordination qui permet de prendre
en compte toute l'interministérialité de
ses enjeux et donc cette prière cette
priorité pardon je souhaite qu'elle soit
mise en oeuvre dans le cadre du
Parlement de la mer que nous avons qui
est le Conseil national de la mer et des
littoraux qui au fond notre instance de
concertation principale qui réunit les
usagers de la mer les ONG les élus de
tous les territoires et les services de
l'État c'est dans cet instant que sera
discuté la stratégie nationale pour la
mère et le littoral que nous aurons à
construire d'ici 2023 c'est dans cet
instant que nous allons porter les
priorités sur les grands fonds marins
que nous allons décliner les
investissements et que nous allons
prendre en compte les spécificités des
territoires et pour répondre à votre
deuxième recommandation monsieur le
rapporteur
je nommerai une personne qui s'occupera
de se pilotage des grands fonds marins
qui fera le lien entre l'aspect
financier France 2030 et la
planification que nous aurons à établir
partout sur cette territoire c'est cette
gouvernance je le crois qui nous
permettra de concerter de faire mieux de
décider et de financer des priorités sur
les grands fonds marins qui répondent à
tous les objectifs que vous avez défini
et puis nous aurons et c'était une des
recommandations aussi de vos rapports
d'augmenter d'amplifier notre soutien à
notre capacité de recherche je pense ici
au CNRS à l'Ifremer et à l'IRD et nous
aurons à mobiliser toutes les forces de
la recherche française pour atteindre un
double objectif la préservation de
l'océan et l'exploration des grands
fonds vous l'aurez compris ce sujet est
porté au plus haut niveau par le
Président de la République dans le cadre
de France mer 2030 et par la première
ministre avec ce comité interministériel
de la mer et une coordination qui se
fera au niveau de mon ministère
nous devons concentrer et vous l'avez
dit vous avez été plusieurs à l'évoquer
toute notre attention tous nos
financements sur l'exploration
l'exploration uniquement pour la
recherche scientifique pour mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement des
écosystèmes et le rôle des grands fonds
marins dans le système océanique et
climatique je vous donnais un exemple le
projet de planeur sous-marin français
pour étudier le volcan sous-marin de
Mayotte ou encore les campagnes en mer
avec l'utilisation d'un drone développé
par une entreprise française est mise en
oeuvre par l'ifremière au milieu de
l'Atlantique tout cela se fera en
parallèle d'une action forte à
l'international avec pour objectif
d'avancer vers une stratégie
internationale multinationale
multinationales porno multilatérale sur
les grands fonds marins la France
n'exploite pas dans ces eaux
territoriales et nous sommes mobilisés
pour convaincre les autres pays de
s'engager dans cette voie de
l'interdiction de l'exploitation en
faisant tout cela sous l'égide de la IFM
que nous aurons à transformer notamment
sur la partie des financements l'enjeu
est bien évidemment d'être suffisamment
de pays à défendre cette position pour
que ce soit celle qui l'emporte alors
vous le voyez les sujets de recherche
sont nombreux par la France et devront
se faire en coordination avec les enjeux
stratégiques de maîtrise des grands
fonds marins de défense et de
surveillance de nos territoires c'est
toute l'ambition de la stratégie du
ministère des armées qui accompagne
cette stratégie d'exploration des fonds
marins alors monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
cette ambition scientifique et bien là
et je sais que c'est une ambition
collective partagée par le Sénat et à
vous entendre je fais le vœu ou en tout
cas je suis convaincu que nous allons
atteindre nos deux objectifs faire de la
France un leader sur l'exploration des
fonds marins avec un défi celui de la
connaissance scientifique pour ce que ce
dernier espace inexploré de la planète
soit mieux connu nos concitoyens et puis
je terminerai par là madame monsieur le
Président pardon sauter des moyens pour
accroître cette connaissance les
missions que nous avons lancées
permettent aussi de tester les matériels
français pour toujours être à la pointe
en matière scientifique je terminerai
par une citation que je trouve très
belle il regardait monter en un ciel
ignoré du fond de l'océan des étoiles
nouvelles et donc continuons à porter
son ambition maritime pour notre pays
merci de votre implication j'ai envie de
vous dire longue vie à la mer la
République et vive la france merci
monsieur le ministre
merci la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Canevet président de la mission de la
formation exploration protection
exploitation des fonds marins quelle
stratégie pour la France pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je voudrais tout d'abord
remercier les différents orateurs des
groupes qui ont pu relayer la vingtaine
de recommandations que la mission a pu
élaborer et puis donner bien entendu des
éclairages particuliers sur un certain
nombre d'aspects je voudrais tout
particulièrement remercier le rapporteur
tevarovic pour l'excellent travail qui a
été mené remercié aussi l'équipe de
collaborateurs menée par Catherine
Forgeard qui a pu assister la mission
pour que ce travail soit vraiment un
travail efficace à la mission à auditer
un certain nombre d'experts plus de 60
experts et réaliser un gros travail mais
il faut dire que la dimension politique
sur romarin est absolument essentiel et
il faut le rappeler et ceci bien sûr
doit nous conduire à continuer à
investir très largement dans les fonds
marins parce que cela a été dit à de
nombreuses reprises il y a pas grand
chose de connu sur les grands formats
donc il faut qu'on continue
l'exploration pour que la science puisse
nous informer de faire connaître tout ce
qu'il y a de richesse dans les fonds
marins et puis pour cela c'est clair il
faut des moyens il faut des moyens bien
entendu pour soutenir la recherche il
faut des moyens cela a été dit tout à
l'heure aussi pour le renouvellement de
la flotte océanique ce fut un des
éléments qui ont permis à l'Ifremer en
particulier d'être particulièrement
reconnu sur la scène internationale au
plan de la connaissance maritime il
importe que les frères puissent être
dotés des outils lui permettant de
continuer à orienter des recherches et
les mener bien entendu et
on ira bien entendu la préoccupation de
Philippe folio sur l'avenir du Nautile
qui est effectivement un outil
extrêmement important alors la France
c'est une ambition maritime je suis
heureux que je vais le guerriot est
aussi affirmé la nécessaire ambition
m'arrêter de la Bretagne à 5
départements comme les tactuellement la
Normandie n'est-ce pas Jean-Michel
Houlgate il n'y a pas de raison que nous
soyons pas aussi bons que la Normandie
mais surtout la Bretagne a de tout temps
un lien historique très fort avec la
mère et la porte que cela puisse
continuer alors vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre des crédits ont été prévus
dans le plan France 2030 322 millions
d'euros il faut effectivement que ces
crédits puissent soutenir un certain
nombre d'actions alors pas seulement en
subventionnant quelques projets mais en
accentuant je crois la commande publique
nous l'avons constaté notamment par des
rencontres avec les industriels
et la porte que nous soyons actifs sur
ce plan-là nous avons pu en over en
Norvège en particulièrement observé que
il y avait un soutien à la commande
publique qui était opérant et qui ont
permis un certain nombre d'industriels
d'être aussi extrêmement efficace il
faut que la France puisse le faire aussi
et ça c'est important parce que nous ne
sommes plus disons-le très clairement
dans la science-fiction aujourd'hui
on le voit parce que notamment il y a
des autorisations qui ont été données
pour l'exploitation à nos rues donc une
filiale du Canadien TMC pour des
explorations de
modules polymétriques dans la zone de
Clarion Clipperton soyons clairs donc
tout ceci appelle notamment vous l'avez
dit monsieur le ministre à une
consolidation de l'autorité
internationale des fonds marins bien sûr
pour un code midi qui soit efficace pour
des moyens de contrôle qui soit
accentués pour un financement qui soit
modifié et puis cela a été dit tout à
l'heure aussi notamment par Joël
guerriot la guerre des fonds marins est
aujourd'hui particulièrement importante
on l'a vu dans la mer Baltique mais cela
peut survenir aussi dans l'Atlantique
dans la Méditerranée dans
l'indopécifique ou l'ado
Océanie il y a donc besoin de mener une
protection extrêmement forte parce que
nous avons des enjeux énergétiques des
enjeux de télécommunications des enjeux
de maintien de la biodiversité aussi qui
sont essentiels dans ces régions et donc
il importe qu'elle a aussi nous
puissions nous préparer assez enjeux
futurs qui sont absolument nécessaires
pour le 21e siècle alors je voudrais en
concluant vous dire que la question des
grands fonds marins est absolument
importante dans notre pays parce qu'il y
a des enjeux de souveraineté économique
cela a été dit de souveraineté
industrielle de souveraineté militaire
je viens d'en parler et puis aussi de
souveraineté écologique disons-le ne
l'oublions pas et donc c'est un grand
enjeu pour le 21e siècle il faut que la
France puisse y participer de toute sa
place il prend toute sa part merci de
votre attention et merci de la
participation de tous à ce débat et aux
propositions qui ont pu être formulées
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je vais lever la séance prochaine séance
mercredi 5 octobre à 15h pour les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement la
séance est levée